ok tu remplaces terry je suis en place à
toutes les poussières qui fait une
entrée
je ne fais pas ce soir je ne fais pas
non à ben d'accord
[Musique]
fascinante rennes
ok ok ok je fais l'entrée hockey
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au milieu d'hommes en noir
[Musique]
avec nous ce soir eddy mitchell
scott thomas
signe de v jean cau
[Applaudissements]
dans une finale
si sincère d
alors
j'en reviens gaz elle dit
nicolas
c'est comme ça
simon liberati
[Applaudissements]
alors on a dit
[Musique]
oh
voici eddy mitchell
alors si vous n'êtes pas venu pour rien
tiens livre un album illustré de 200
photos un texte de sam bernett qui
raconte votre vie du rockeur aux
couleurs voilà alors c'est un livre très
intéressant c'est moi ce que j'aime en
fait dans les bio des stars c'est
l'enfance voilà alors naissance en 42 du
côté de la place des fêtes dans le 19e
arrondissement
vos parents s'appelle lucienne et robert
c'est nerveux non mais ça fait un peu
film de lelouch kuzeo lucienne et robert
j nat et marcel et oui c'est un peu ça
la soeur s'appelle gisèle et le frère
s'appelle pierre vous vous êtes le petit
dernier le petit gâtés oui des clones un
oui le petit chouchou quoi ni un petit
chouchou de l'appel way oui mais alors
vous voulez pas sur l'or dans cette
famille le soir pour dîner vous dit on
on met un morceau de pain dans un bol de
vin rouge quoi c'est quand même été ça
ah ça c'est l'été à l'hiver c'est quoi
une bonne grosse soupe non oui et puis
la fin du mois se termine le 15
avant j'allais la cour votre père héros
discret de la résistance mais qui se
retrouve comme à bosser à la ratp quoi
comme votre père travaille la nuit le
jour il a le temps de s'occuper de vous
il vous amène voir des western des
thrillers des péplums dans les cinémas
de quartier
il vous amène voir des combats de catch
et c'est lui finalement kivu forme
complètement quoi ah oui donc totalement
et puis même au niveau au niveau
littérature parce que mon père était
très très très ouvert lisait de tous
allaient de aussi bien de puisqu'à
l'époque
la grande star du polar c'était plus
tard schéma aussi bien plus tard chemin
en passant par sartre fallait tout
manger ouais donc vous lisiez les livres
de peter chan et vous allez voir la môme
vert de gris avec un ris constantine
ouais c'est toute une culture c'est vrai
bah oui oui c'est vrai oui c'est
important c'est bien mais alors vous
n'avez pas beaucoup aux lycéens faut
bien le dire non à vous préférez draguer
fumée glander 1
c'est plutôt ça votre sur vos haches et
c'est quand même plus heureux alors dans
la famille des dix mises à part votre
père qui travaille la ratp la nuit tout
le monde travaille au crédit lyonnais
donc vous vous retrouvez est coursier à
lagence richelieu drouot bientôt vous
êtes viré parce qu'en tant que court si
évidemment vous barrez sur la boutique
mobylette et vous avez tout faire sauf
sauf du travail et et finalement vous
êtes viré mais cette expérience vous
permet de découvrir ce qu'on appelle le
triangle d'or c'est à dire entre les
grands boulevards le square de la
trinité la rue richelieu et là vous
rencontrer deux autres glandeurs
passionné de rock qui sont johnny
hallyday et jacques dutronc est ce que
je trouve assez extraordinaire quand
même c'est si cette rencontre quoi les
trois plus grands jouer ensemble à
l'adolescence c'est très bizarre quand
même un merveilleux hasard oui mais
c'est un hasard extraordinaire sera
merveilleux heskey de surtout de
merveilleux c'est qu'on soit resté non
seulement très bons termes mais qu'on
soit vraiment les amis je représente a
rencontré dick rivers
c'est marrant la vie je t aime ici je
connais bien ses seins lui il était né
soit est alors bientôt vous découvrez le
golf drouot qui deviendra le berceau du
rock français
nous quand on l'a
connue c'était un endroit pour vieille
dame qui me prendre le thé le café
d'emblée d'un arrêt au dessus du café
d'angleterre c'était vraiment un
minigolf un golf miniature donc que 400
un trou dans ses rien fait rien alors ce
qui est drôle c'est votre première
rencontre si je savais pas avec jean
philippe smet donc futur géniale idée il
vous piquent des disques c'est vraiment
main ne coûtait pas très loin de vitré
de marty est une une surprise party
comme l'on dit est donc bon j'avais
amené des lices comme tous les gamins
comme tout qu'on ne nous étions et en
partant quand ça se termine faleyras
embarqués et les miens j'ai trouvé pas
et avec mon camarade johnny qui lui les
avait confiés au concierge en disant je
repasserai les prendre plus tard voilà
et a voulu coller au mur qu'un but
récupérer attendait c'était les premiers
45 tours jean vincent sasso but donc
entre johnny et vous ça a commencé par
un parent baston quoi aux bastons porte
pas bien méchant brahim de gamins et
puis pourquoi tu aimes ça parce que
j'aime ça mais hélas ce qu on a parlé de
choses beaucoup plus importantes que
dutronc qui à l'époque était un vrai
dandy chapeau enfoncé jusqu'aux oreilles
imperméable cintrée à la taille
oui c'est vrai qu'il avait un côté on
l'appelait liasse tondre m car il se
tenait exprès pour pour le gag se tenait
toujours goûter avec un imperméable et à
l'époque il avait des foyers triple trip
des verts triple foyer comme ça et il
quand il variait on appelait ça
l'opération gitane
c'était avant sa métamorphose parce
qu'après les truies après c'est devenu
le playboy qu'il est toujours lancé
l'époque que vous récoltez le surnom de
schmoll une fille qui s'appelait la
valise parce qu'elle avait un des envies
les normes paraît-il
non
franchement non elle avait une
intelligence très proche d'un maillage
est d'ailleurs le plus drôle c'est que
je les croisais il ya peu de temps en
temps il ya la valise valérie labbé me
wade les croisés à saint tropez moi je
l'embrassais ci est laissée par le son
poste et j'ai même pas eu le temps du
alia bonjour la valise comment ça va
puis hop est parti alors à l'époque vous
formez votre premier groupe qui
s'appelle les five rocks 1
mais quand il ya le premier passage sur
europe 1 vous découvrez vous appelez les
chaussettes noires parce qu'il avait un
deal entre votre maison de disques à un
marchand de chaussettes techniques
sociales ce thème ce thème greenway et
bon j'ai appris par la radio j'ai appelé
les chaussettes noires franchement ça
vous a fait quoi se faisait humilier
tous appelé le show c'est toi c'était un
peu dur quand même
c'était même pas humiliation c'était
consternation maintenant les jeux
annoncés tout ça était pas important
parce que on pensait qu'on avait fait un
vin est fait un disque on se c'était
amusant et puis non 45 ans l'étape et
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai nom nous
avons aujourd'hui une fatwa
en tous les cas le succès est immédiat
vous avez du succès tout de suite avec
tu parles trop bebopalula daniela et
vous vendez en deux ans deux millions de
10 comme ça à l'époque c'était c'était
énorme
mais bien sûr non mais bon vous prenez
ça comme ça mais c'est quand même
extraordinaire oui mais pas contre c'est
normal
ouais non plus le truc drôle c'est que
c'est vrai ah bon bah c'est bien c'est
formidable puis on ne veut pas enfin on
se rendait pas bien contre est un
problème c'est que vous partez à l'armée
et d'eads dont ont fait preuve faire
comme si on n'a pas de temps à prendre a
craint pas encore de raz soyez soyez
tranquille sur les retraites l'histoire
du même nom
à un moment il faut qu'on leur rende
modèle d'accord voilà alors après vous
faites quelques succès il ya toujours un
coin qui me rappelle s'il n'en reste
qu'un alice enfin début de votre
carrière solo dont il ya comme une
longue traversée du désert j'ai revu ça
en lisant ce bouquin je me souvenais pas
ça va mal hein il ya une période comme
ça qui dure 4 5 ans où vous êtes quand
même culture
quatre ans à la ramasse quand même passé
un moment
il envisage même de reformer le sétois
enfin vous voulez pas un enfant c'était
on vous le propose
oui mais ce matin s'ils vous dire à quel
point ça allait mal oui oui non mais
c'est vrai que je vendais très très peu
de disques et
et que ce qui faisait peur c'est culés
les anciens discothèque était reproposer
en compilant ce solvant mais mieux ouais
oui le best-of des chaussettes noires se
vendait mieux vaut 10 terrible ça ça
c'est ce qui arrive à dave tous les ans
vous me direz un à un ils étaient pas
dans les chaussettes noires non à ce
moment là vous faites une émission est
une émission de radio qui s'appelle en
attendant que ça se passe donc c'est
bien la preuve vous aviez le sentiment
même que c'était un moment qui ne marche
pas non plus du barça avant
c'est terrible le nom qui marchent pas
dans s'était enfin c'est drôle c'est pas
drôle c'est
j'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle au
fond du trou kim en ce moment mais ça va
pas dans tes honorent leur décollage
nous vivier de quoi à l'époque j'ai
tourné où je n'avais pas envie d'aller
d'ailleurs je tournais dans les pays de
l'est roumanie machin tout ça est que le
chou farci tout ce qu'on aime bien
et je gagnais très bien ma vie mais je
n'étais pas très drôle moi non il là
c'est le drame non justement nos rangs
c'est le grand retour
le
au moins
non
ap
sa peau
ce dieu
allo
m
spot
dieu points
[Musique]
le remporter
seconde
entrée 8 euros
[Applaudissements]
avec satellite en khl
qui poursuit mon talent
voilà eddy mitchell c'est
son extrait du cd le plein si tort ça
c'est des trucs que vous avez chanté il
ya
il a exactement chanson ça non non non
il ya une nouvelle enfin quand même le
cd interprétation d'aujourd'hui ne
laisser aucune chance aux époques voilà
c'est logique mais j'aime bien c'est son
bien belle voix c'est incroyable
quarante ans après avoir commencé
vous êtes toujours là avait la pêche les
les
les gens vous à plat de lèche la banane
1 l'armée c'est bien non bah moi je suis
ravie seriez cruas 1 kessel a duré
quarante ans non mais même de faim je
reconnais que je suis pas une inondant
dans ce cas je pensais c'est merci merci
tous les jours c'est rien est à
mi-parcours ça va durer encore jeanne
calment n'y aura qu'à voir n'a pas fini
d'en bouffer
o o
je
je suis
eddy mitchell je sens encore ceux qui
ont les blues
alors ai dit vous êtes vous êtes un
rocker maintenant je sais pas si c'est
une rock star va faire un test
le rockstar test
est ce que vous êtes né dans la rue je
peux enfin je sais pas j'ai pas de
souvenir cet âge là un souvenir très
bien est ce que vous êtes déjà battu
pendant un nouveau concert battue ouais
à we are et c'était bon
c'était en corse à bastia il est même
coup de la tête personnages et aux fins
d'en c'est vrai
on avait posé son sac et un pont sal ar
avec le réalisateur avec le réalisateur
voulait pas compilé la boîte à
chaussures avec les pieds dedans
non ils voulaient pas me donner des
leçons aux autres il disait que mariano
chantait sans micro qui avait pas de
raison
ouais bon vieux murs peints à l'huile
alors est-ce que vous avez déjà couché
avec votre cousine
non jamais non non il a fait lui oui
mais je vis et je joue pas de piano non
plus loin c'est vrai
est ce que vous êtes déjà mort dans un
accident d'avion non s'il rappelle toi
la réponse est non sympa ça je prends
landau j'ai bon est ce que vous avez
déjà saccagé une chambre d'hôtel oui
c'est vrai il a pissé à côté une fois
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait une
overdose au palace non non vous a déjà
chanté du charles trenet oui quoi que
reste-t-il de nos amours la mer entre
autres est-ce que vous avez déjà chanté
avec maurice chevalier
ouais c'est mauvais ça pour être
rockstar
ah bon ouais mais lui c'est pas cool et
on n'entend plus parler fait du bien le
twist du canotier
est-ce que vous avez déjà été inquiété
pour des problèmes de drogue dans un
aéroport américain
non je suis mauvais vous êtes un mauvais
vous n'êtes pas est un rockeur est pas
une rock star
ah bon vous avez déjà demandé obispo de
pas vous composer des chansons
c'est vrai c'est pas gentil excuse et
quelque chose en nous de tennessee
regarde regarde bien damée enfin ça
c'est paris qui ont la cote on connaît
les tendances sexuelles de tennessee
williams joue mieux pas d'accord bonne
réponse vous êtes j'ai été agressé par
un fan honnêtement pas non pas comme les
danois n'ont encore un dont on entend
peu parler dit elle c'est parce qu'il
faut j'ai déjà allé sur le plateau de la
star academy pour faire de la promo oui
deux fois oui
non moi moi je vérifie un non mais
attendez ça paye mieux qui suit 1
bien on y va et d excuse a été de boire
ou de fumer non plus ça c'est bien
maintenant aller pour être star c'est
bien avant avec les excès il faut faire
beaucoup d'excès abo j'ai mangé beaucoup
de boulot vous vous jetez dans votre
public à la fin d'un concert faisait
garde
ouais c'est kristin scott thomas
[Applaudissements]
alors
vous êtes
vous êtes rares télévision on voit
rarement sur les plateaux de télévision
n'est donc d'autant plus content et
flatté que vous soyez là christine voilà
je sais que vous n'aimez pas les gens
qui sont impressionnés par vous vous
dites ça me met mal à l'aise alors je
vais essayer de pas être trop
impressionné par vos tanks et moi les
gens mal à l'aise ça m'impressionne la
façon alors en fait je crois que vous
êtes pas du tout consciente de l'effet
que vous produisez vous dites les gens
fantasment à cause de mes rôles il
imagine que j'ai une espèce de pouvoir
de séduction c'est archi faux
je ne peux pas labourer mais le jeu oui
oui oui oui c'est pas vous êtes très
joli très sensibles à ces s'arrête et
chiant c'est très sympathique merci
relou en fait alors en fait christine se
trouve pas belle mais si elle le dit
elle a peur de passer pour quelqu'un qui
aurait de la fausse modestie
c'est très compliqué mais c'est vous que
trois à bon en tout cas ça vous rend
encore plus attachantes et plus belle
alors vous écris en angleterre d'une
famille très chic
si tout va comme il faut quand une
famille connaissait une femme est
anormal mais pas chic
ouais comme il faut je sais pas mais
comme il faut comme il nous fallait en
tout cas comme il fallait alors votre
vie ça commence comme un roman votre
père était pilote de chasse il est mort
quand vous aviez cinq ans votre mère se
remarie avec un autre pilote de chasse
qui meurent six ans après c'est
incroyable non oui mais vrai mais vrai
c'est le même incroyable et est restée
est très difficile pour elle et pour
nous les enfants c'était très difficile
enfin ça c'est des choses qu'on qui nous
fabriquent en face des expériences comme
ça c'est des choses qui qui nous donne
le caractère donc faut pas pleurer je
suis réussi vous avez commencé la
comédie très tôt à l'âge de 4 ans vous
juillet un berger était aussi un berger
un vieux berger en effet avec une canne
c'est pas un peu tard quatre ans pour
jouer un vieillard mais alors très vite
vous êtes aperçu que c'était là que vous
étiez bien quoi c'était quand vous étiez
en représentation j'aimais beaucoup me
déguiser faire semblant d'être quelqu'un
d'autre et je continue c'est petit et ce
soir vous fait l'actrice qui a fait un
film avec régis wargnier vous le faites
très bien d'ailleurs
alors votre famille vous décourage de
faire de la comédie parce que par sens
des convenances se faisait pas et vous
décidez de devenir professeur d'art
dramatique ce que tu es une sans doute
une idée est fatale oui j'ai enfin je me
suis inscrit dans une classe où on
apprenait être professeur et je me suis
vite aperçu que c'était vraiment pas la
bonne voie et que pour faire ce que je
voulais faire il fallait que je quitte
l'angleterre et que je recommence à
nouveau que quelques braillards et voilà
et c'est là que la france ait hérité de
kristin scott thomas vous deviez 19 ans
vous êtes venus ici comme jeune fille au
pair dans une famille et c'est cette
famille qui vous encourager à faire le
métier des gamins encouragés à faire ce
que je voulais faire
et c'était à cause c'est d'ailleurs et
je me souviens très bien j'avais
tellement peur d'aller au delà au
concours de la rue blanche que qu'elle
m'a mis elle même dehors et donc j'ai
jamais reparti de france ma maison chez
moi c'est si oui faut dire que vous avez
rencontré un français ça c'est fatal
aussi à l'époque
à l'époque il était étudiant en médecine
oui faso c'est la vie privée on va pas
trop en parler mais c'est un aujourd'hui
un grand médecin
quelle spécialité fois la série c et les
obstétriciens là j'arrive pas à le dire
je préfère ce soir christine qu'il des
otsi sociale
j'arrive pas à le dire le fameux six
hommes fredrik je ne sais pas des mots
moi ya des mots que je sais pas dire
sans rire en bateau non mais attendez un
petit risque et pas un mot facile mieux
en province il a osé trois grands
enfants 1
et alors à cause d'eux à cause de ses
enfants donc vous n'avez pas fait de
carrière à hollywood c'est parce que
j'ai choisi de
de privilégier la vie française la vie
que je pouvais trouver ici avec ma
famille mes enfants plutôt que cave elle
est là bas et avoir à faire des choses
qui m'attirait plus tellement en fait je
suis allé je suis j'ai fait un tour et
puis je suis revenu vous regrettez pas
jamais si parfois quand les ans à des
pleurs si parfois on se dit oh j'aurais
dû rester et puis on a plus de liberté
et si bizarrement les femmes de mon âge
dans le cinéma américain c'est très très
très difficile
et là vous voyez les rôles que je viens
de jouer là uniquement en france avec
arsène lupin et puis man to man et
petites coupures c'est faux c'est
fantastique c'est fabuleux c'est fait
les méchantes et en ce moment un oui
j'ai eu une période méchante c'est fini
la manche et je suis plutôt dans les
comédies normalement d'accord alors en
préparant cette interview je me suis
rendu compte que c'est pas la première
fois que vous jouiez avec il des pygmées
en 86 et under the cherry moon et print
santé laval
quand la santé cette santé l'absolu mais
ce film nader dutch high moon vous
n'avez pas mis dans votre filmographie
un aussi bon elle doit l'être
ouais c'est pas je ne pense pas non
annoncée à faire de ce que si c'est si
je suis très fier de ce film c'était mon
premier film je jouais au théâtre dans
un champ en bourgogne une caisse de
margrit braz et tout d'un coup on
m'appelle pour me demander d'aller faire
des essais avec primes ce qui était à
l'époque normand
et puis je me suis trouvé dans une
limousine en allant à nice je n'avais
jamais essayé dans un hôtel de ma
musique à la et là c'était les hôtels 4
étoiles c'était mignon bon arrêtez vous
je vais craquer alors vous êtes sans
doute l'anglais ce qui connaît le mieux
les français je crois qu'on est
plusieurs à koné
jane birkin et vous charlotte alors
affaire à french quiz
[Musique]
alors christine est ce que le français
fait tout le temps la gueule oui nature
des et encore
rappelons qu'elle ne prend pas le métro
est ce que le français a vraiment une
hygiène douteuse
peut-être que non à
est-ce que le français se croient
vraiment supérieur aux autres
non non je dirais même contraire à boire
avant vous vous pensez que les fonctions
à un petit complexe d'infériorité oui
oui vous dit on sur wii parce que je me
sens je me sens quand même adopté et je
me suis adapté
donc voilà
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez beaucoup mieux le français
que cette berline est ce que le français
vraiment nuls en langues étrangères pas
insinue que les anglais les américains
est ce que le français est vraiment prêt
à dénoncer son voisin si on le lui
demande
à metz que le français est un mec
vraiment les touristes quand ils
viennent en france
ah ça je ne sais pas parce que jamais
ces touristes en battant kit est vendu
ce motorola
[Applaudissements]
est ce que le pense et dragueur j'ai du
mal à repérer les mêmes pendant l'acte
est en train de me draguer
pas du tout est ce que le français passe
vraiment son temps à parler de sexe non
est ce que le français embrasse bien
est-ce que le français fait bien l'amour
est ce que le français sympathique n'en
demandent pas trop tirer mais si gezin
deviers joncour
[Musique]
magnifique christine deviers-joncour cdu
quoi ça du lapin ah le pauvre
comment ça va bah ça va pas mal piscine
de 10 en cours on vous a connu
[ __ ] de la république à elle et ça
nous rend vous a connu chanteuse et
maintenant vous êtes écrivain non mais
j'ai écrit quatre livres tels 5e ou ne
la suit l'annoncé de sa romance c'est
vraiment les autres c'était pour les
affaires au moins un outil complet pour
me défendre me battre là on souffle on
parle d'autre chose qu on parle de cul
de la brigitte christine vous êtes une
vraie touche à tout oui oui allait bien
alors ensuite christine enfin connu
chanteuse et là on a découvert avec
stupeur bon de la sortie du disque que
toute votre enfance deviez travailler le
piano avec un grand musicien espagnol
qui avait fui le franquisme qui s'était
réfugié à sarlat et que normalement vous
auriez dû être christine deviers-joncour
chef d'orchestre compositeur
voilà comme bénin fini sa carrière elle
a toujours mené les hommes à la baguette
je ne sais pas qui a mené c'est dur de
commencer à 55 ans pour une jeune
chanteuse pourquoi vous dites mon âge
moi je dis aime bien on en a mangé des
poils blonds n'est pas de la première
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez quoi vous pensez quoi
sérieusement question vous pensez quoi
de ces nouveaux chanteurs qui ne savent
pas chanter qui vendent des millions
d'albums
alors que vous en demander beaucoup
moins vous savez pas chanter en plus je
sais pas je ne sais pas chanter je crois
que d'abord j'ai eu envie de décrire
c'est une sage m'exprimer c'est ce qui
m'a motivé en même temps la musique j'ai
toujours baigné est bon si ça marche ça
marche moi je me fais plaisir c'est le
principal ne croyez pas vous auriez dû
chanter pour ceux qui sont loin de chez
eux qu'ils ont dans les yeux quelque
chose qui fait mal je pense vous
regretté de pas avoir écrit votre chance
en vous même mais je les écris moi même
ça tu regrettes pas t'as pas écouté
l'album si je le dire après je vais
coûtent deux fois par an il n'en est pas
sorti presque
oui
eh bien j'ai un secret je l'écoutais la
bonne vitesse ça y est on commence bien
alors donc un [ __ ] de la république
deux chanteuses trois écrivains un livre
après un disque voulait vraiment on est
en prison christine non parce que là
j'ai instauré un passionnant qu'on parle
pas d' affaire d'état par rapport à
votre place si vous auriez pas mieux
fait de sortir une ligne de chaussures
non vous n'êtes plus sociaux alors le
livre s'appelle comme le disent que toi
masculin mon féminin c'est aux éditions
du rocher
et c'est un roman érotique alors vous
dites j'ai écrit ce livre pour ne pas
mourir
au lendemain du procès en appel après la
relaxe de dumas en voyant que je prenais
encore les coûts qui est vrai que j'ai
passé quelques mois très durs
ouais j'avais plus tellement d'avenir
dans l'essex ouvert ce membre tuméfié
semble prendre naissance à l'âge et la
gauloise
je note aussi quelques passages alors
c'est l'histoire d'une femme à la dérive
qui vit encore dans le souvenir du grand
amour de sa vie
le grand amour de sa vie c'est un homme
plus âgé qui l'a marqué à jamais mais
qu'il l'a jamais épousé etc est mort
roland dumas est mort non c'est pas je
vais donc je ne peux pas caché qu
effectivement l'héroïne je me suis
complètement week-end très bien sûr
parce que j'avais aussi à travers à
travers 16 j'avais besoin de faire des
choses donc effectivement et aussi
peut-être
j'ai voulu montrer une femme une femme
qui s'est battu et a pris des sacré coup
dans la gueule
et cette femme se retrouve dans bâle
après ce grand amour donc acariens avec
cet homme elle n'a plus rien n'est
complètement aguerris et elle retombe
amoureux
voilà alors demain qui au départ est
très macho et on découvre rapidement que
c'est une folle tordue balcik en exige
la clé d'or
il adore se travestir il attend et c'est
un jeu c'est certain on a tous en nous
du masculin du fidjien tournoi en donnes
moi j'ai peut-être fait féminine je
crois que j'ai beaucoup de masculin en
moi et je me suis dit en écrivant ce que
j'avais besoin de vivre une histoire
d'amour que je vis pas c'est vrai un peu
seul depuis sept ans et je me suis
immergé là dedans et je me suis dit
voyons quel est le genre d'homme qui
pourrait me faire me faire peut-être
attendez on était jeunes on imaginer un
homme en soit la verse deux mois c'est à
dire à la fois masculin féminin jouer je
pressentais que c'est son plus haut fait
vrai tadjau après ton pied dans le 9 3
c'est quoi le lâche 3 à wigan astra le
moment je suis pas allé mais on donne
raison
je connais personne dans la visite tu
veux connaître du monde très bien et
bombay donnera une autre nuit c'est une
page 24
donc c'est un soir glace et de pleine
lune donc oui si vous êtes vous êtes
avec le vieux c'est à venger alors elle
se déshabille derrière un four il fait
très froid il fait bien sûr je voudrais
à lui dévêtue voilà et alors je ne
craignais plus froids de mort qui
trahissaient comme une douleur
j'avançais encore j'imaginais le
spectacle qui s'offrait à lui je
jubilais à un mètre de lui je m'arrêter
il s'approcha haute à sa vareuse qu'il
posa à même le sol sur l'herbe givre est
saisi ma main et l'invita et m'invite à
m'allonger j'obéis son corps recouvrit
sans aucun préliminaire il écarta mais
en tout cas c'est bien conjuguer parce
que les kartings mes jambes ce qui ne
voulait rien et les cartes à ce mes
jambes tout est bien conjuguer en tout
cas sa ceinture brutale comme un viol je
senti ça que red me pénétrer écarter les
chères comme une déchirure son désir
était violent un patient
ces coups de boutoir
ces coups de boutoir coulé au fond de
mon ventre voilà voilà ça c'est la mort
du vieux quoi pratiquer vous devez tuer
et donc effectivement après cette
aventure avec ce set up disons d'un âge
mûr
l'héroïne est complètement déboussolée
elle prête à quitter paris et la
rencontre le fameux francesco qui est un
riche businessman
alors il ya un truc que je supporte pas
c'est qu'il est fier de frauder le fisc
c'est une image annonce est pas une
image
moi je trouve que c'est pas bien mais
pas fier je dis je raconte que
qu'effectivement il est comme beaucoup
c'est à dire 20 % de français
aujourd'hui qui se demandent comment ils
vont faire et qui se délocalise que
celles au 15
vous dites la réussite qu'il faut
planquer sous peine de davy d'abus de
biens sociaux
c'est pas vrai quand sur l'argent propre
sur lequel on a payé ses impôts on peut
s'acheter tout ce qu'on veut en france
ce qui est interdit c'est acheter des
trucs est très brouillon de la société à
606 ici c'est très simple c'est
vachement bien payer des impôts chanter
toute ma vie que moi ça va à quelqu'un
ça aide les gens oui ça fait d'écraser
des hôpitaux dans sérieuses avancées
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens que je
paye des impôts et ne bénéficient pas de
certaines choses comme un citoyen normal
quoi
j'appelle la police c'est pas la même
histoire ils viennent quand ils
n'appellent pas le problème
non mais quand je vis la réussite qu'il
faut planquer sous peine de délit d'abus
de biens sociaux
c'est pas vrai quand on peut s'acheter
ce qu'on veut avec l'argent
dites propres aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
montrent une entreprise qui a acquis à
la force du poignet pendant des années
la montre et sa propre entreprise à
créer de l'emploi et qui moi c'est ça
n'arrive j'entends ça autour de moi tous
les jours et qui achètent je sais pas
j'exagère mais un billet d'avion pour
les vacances et de la bd messieurs c'est
sa propre entreprise et c'est pas non
mais c'est ça les gens sont faussés
qu'ils s'en aillent cela parce que je
vais vous dire ça c'est de l'abus de
bien social effectivement s'acheter des
billets d'avion reprendront vallée en
vacances sur les frais de la société
c'est pour ça c'est un délit c'est un
abus de bien social et c'est interdit et
c'est normal voilà
[Applaudissements]
je pars délégué le summum enfin quand
même énormément les gens qui connaissent
pas tout ça ils demandent même pour des
petites distances même pour le net
positif si c'est pas professionnel on
paye avec son pote d'accès comme si
c'est vrai que ma main paraît rien à
plat qui s'en vont et qui sans elle je
vous dis cela comme moi j'ai rien contre
qui sans abri mais qui s'en va et on
s'en fout canap la voilà nous on reste
non mais moi je suis là voilà bon alors
elle baise avec francesco donc alors
vous dites un amant un recul issus
martine aubry la légine un peu roberto
et au bar chez vous qui avez écrit le
bouquin c'est pas moi alors ils vont en
vacances ensemble et la tendance à
porter des sous vêtements féminins race
effectivement le vtt c'est assez chaud
là quelle page quelle page 82 bien sûr
on peine se fait plus rageuse et secoue
la palmeraie les partenaires du musée de
jasmin sont enivrantes effluves le tissu
s'envole parce que le mec a mis la
nuisette soir en plein dans la métaphore
religieuse
les parfums de mer du musée de jasmin
sont des livres en effluves le tissu
s'envole découvrant sa nudité jusqu'à la
taille du mec en retombant tout en
plaquant la soie sur son ventre
le pan de la chemise s'accroche sur son
sexe attendu qu'il laisse ainsi offert
commune assure une provocation
ok je vais me choisir et déjà à ce stade
là on voit pas encore la bible et des
bas mais il n'écoute pas je ne résiste
pas une tentation brutale me dis que
signe de viège en cours devant lui je
m'agenouille jade rendent même mes mains
à travers le vêtement de pau dans ce jeu
les fleurs du bout des doigts qu'est-ce
que s'agir elite est dessiné sous le
velouté du tissu fait plusieurs mexique
davantage alors ça va jusqu'au dîner à
la fin il ya un dîner où ils arrivent
maquillée avec le pousse à l'extrême
mais pourrez vous immerger vrai pas là
mais qu'arrive maquillée avec un porte
jarretelles parce que je trouve ça aussi
aux toxines
0 0 c'est ma mère mais quid pour les
appels mais c'est à la fin donc il faut
un dîner fin le mec se se maquille il
met un porte jarretelles
il se couche par terre c'est des idées
pour vous avec ares avec votre canadien
et l'on vous dit ni feu mais nous y
sommes
les cuisses serre et le sexe des mesures
est offert c'est la mesure la
mensuration tout le temps il lui dit
prends moi ma chérie donc le mec et des
dialogues et alors ces moments où ils
l'attachent magie elle mouille son doigt
pour titiller ses salles le bout de ses
seins du mec jeu mental sur ce pieux
démesurée qui me déchire le ventre c'est
toujours levantin sait jamais la chatte
s'est mise à parler de cul c'est très
joli
cela dépend même pas parce que c'est
très très chaud si la fhp lui en trois
heures hyper chaud j'avais le cul la
mine est calciné est incrusté d'une
épaisse croûte noire
alors moi je te raconterai
allez revenir j'avais effectivement eu
la mine et helsinn est incrusté d'une
épaisse croûte noire c'est la version
bande annonce
mais s'il s'agit des casseroles
[Applaudissements]
la classe quoi
dès lors de whisky je veux bien accepter
rock and roll
q donc ça revient au même et tous les
aveo les casseroles féminin
russell messieurs
alors c'est quoi que les films
sérieusement c'est quoi pour vous l'ami
des halles sérieusement j'y crois plus à
l'homme idéal
c'est un rêve ça de j'ai un amour et je
me suis créé une histoire comme ça et en
privant j'ai vécu quelque chose et j'ai
oublié le reste les affaires des de la
couleur des cheveux de l'homme idéal
pour vous brun la coupe de jeu en fin de
partie mais un peu un prépuce trépied je
voulais lui mais même comme ça je
voulais qu'il soit musclé jusque
dimanche fois surtout face à rennes pas
musclé me bat mais très musclé vague à
tous les civils et qu'ils soient beaux
qu'ils aient de l'argent je m'en fous
quel bord politique voulait qu'il soit
qui fait qu'ils soient d'aucun bord bien
au centre
rien du tout religion je m'en fous la
première chose que l'homme idéal dois
vous dire en se levant au revoir
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant l'idée
que s'il restait
m
qui comme moi être tout aussi bien dit
kevin weeks as
[Musique]
hier au meeting with voilà ce que pierre
dites vous
vous tombez
et voilà ce qu elle une vie de pierre
ainsi d'un groupe g selected un pas
aussi celui-ci souvenirs ça va pas mal
c'est lamentable comme d'habitude fait
d'accord c'est qu'on sait pas qui vise à
masquer les enjeux la peur quand ça va
c'est lamentable bien marré là on est
due à barèges se sent bien et sont bien
site internet laurent david est quand
même
dramaturge mais aussi je crois qu'on
peut le dire c'est vrai heureusement que
j'avais fait un petit bout dans le film
de l'an parce que sinon je parce qu on
retiendrait de votre iphone
d'ailleurs ça a boosté un peu taquin ça
m'a fait ça m'a fait un 10-0 travailler
un peu comme la cuisse et j'étais un peu
un peu dans le
depuis
et voilà elle a sorti d'affaires dit il
est revenue au top il est au top là au
top des vues et vincente briques avec
quelques temps oh là là oui vous a
demandé il vous a demandé quelque chose
de très grave
il vous a dit est-ce que c'est pas
difficile de jouer avec l'homme dont on
partage la vie savait qu'il fallait
penser à celle à 10 ans aurait pas pensé
regarde regarde de ce drame
sage vive la wiener si vous pouvez me
dire un truc je voudrais pas faire une
interview trop en mer dont je vais vous
épargner
non monsieur d'une bonne question plus
c'est vrai mais répondait c'était très
bien le dimanche après midi c'est
ravissant bien tu veux qu au crack de
sang vidéo c'est formidable et oui je la
méritais mais j'aimerais bien la faire
cette émission des gens qui ont des amis
mais c'est ça le problème comme ça peut
pas coller tous tes amis du bien dire
que tu es génial tu crois que moi ça
marcherait pas attendre a tendance à
préférer le 10 minutes
weight gemini tué pierre non
sérieusement j'ai lu dans marie claire
du mois de novembre
non non mon père thierry tu es be j'aime
beaucoup marie ps un très bon là c'était
sympa j'ai lu comment comment quoi
thierry juste après une première
rencontre un soir dans une chambre qui
servait de loges
evelyne bouix ici présentes on en
signera moi j'arrête vous appliquez
nathan et bien non mais ça j'aimerais
devenir chauve là les gens ne croyaient
pas capable de faire ça c'est à dire que
il le pauvre il est là il est où le
plaqué au mur dès le premier soir et non
alors elle vous plaque au mur c'est dans
marie claire donc c'est vrai vous plaque
au mur
avec plusieurs bras ça nous embrasse
comme au cinéma et vous dites un vrai
baiser de voyous s'est fait comme ça et
je n'ai écrasé cet homme et cinéma avec
quel genre de cinéma basque et arditi en
plus à l'époque il était sinon on ne
touchait pas être ne touchez pas donc il
dit vous l'embrassez vous le coller au
mur et après il ya tout un dégagement
sur le baiser que c'est que finalement
on peut faire l'amour mais tant qu'on
embrasse pas on n'aime pas vraiment que
le baiser c'est le premier le premier
acte d'amour enfin le délire absolument
vous ces délits évidemment c'est quand
même appartement quand vous avez aussi
vous embrasser par vous aimez pas c'est
normal je ne sais pas c'est vrai qu'un
film sais pas comment vous comment ça se
passe pour vous non pas moi
personnellement vais vous montrer
[Applaudissements]
c'est lamentable hier voilà forman
service public pas lamentable cadeau
pour toi pierre au nokia
enfin
ah ouais ah bravo long et ben voila je
n'imagine nom avec ses t-shirts à
seignosse que tu te calmes en termes et
ses tuiles c'est foutu il faut que tu le
met
oui je le mettrais moi j'étais à la
maison je mettrai la prochaine fois
parce que là j'ai déjà un pull moi je
vais crever la non mais je le mettrais
je te crois que ce creux des pierres
mais le bien donc ce qu'on voit en tous
les cas à la lumière de cette anecdote
relatée dans ma prière incroyable c'est
qu'en fait c'est un petit peu dans votre
vie quotidienne un petit peu comme au
cinéma non non on va voir on va faire
une interview dans la vraie vie les
concentrés nous pensons très lourd et
vine aussi est ce que dans la vraie vie
il vous arrive de vous jouer la comédie
l'un à l'autre bah non nous on a là on
attend là on à la comédie et on ouvre la
porte à la maison puis boumal comédie
derrière donc à la maison vous êtes
comme en bas la maison n'a pas besoin de
ça en fait autre chose je vous appelle à
la maison je t'aime maman je t'aime
est ce que est ce que dans la vraie vie
il vous arrive d'entendre des
applaudissements dans les moments de
tendresse ou juste après oui pourquoi
il ya sûrement des coups de théâtre dans
votre vie la vraie vie frappe les trois
coups
j'essaie de tant que faire se peut dans
leur mire la brigade
alors là c'est pas là c'est pas
lamentable athée notoire essaye de te
transformer la vie tant que faire se
peut en tout cas le quotidien comme
quelque chose qui est plus magique est
plus mystérieux et plus agréable et plus
rigolo tant que faire se peut alors ça
c'est important est ce que dans la vraie
vie vous fait relâche le lundi
pas du tout non est ce que dans la vraie
vie vous avez déjà trouver un amant dans
le placard non non donc c'est pas du
tout du tout du tout comme au théâtre
finalement la vraie vie pas vraiment non
un entracte non est ce que dans la vraie
vie pierre il ya une scène que vous ne
vous lasserez jamais de jouer avec
evelyne y en a plusieurs
oui j'ai dû y en a au moins une nuit
bien sûr la cassette sk une scène dans
la vraie vie que vous voulez plus jamais
jouer avec elvin il ya des scènes que je
n'aimerais pas avoir à jouer avec
evelyne quoi par exemple les fans qu on
rejouerait bien nettement pour revenir
avec ses précédents il ya des scènes que
je rejoins il a des souvenirs car je ne
voulais je ne vouliez jeune cécile
denjean nourrir oui le parking
l'anecdote du parti pierre en dehors de
la chambre des loges et tout ça quand
elle vous accueillir et à d'autres
endroits cuisine la cuisine abus hongrie
tu crées buanderie pierre ne descend pas
du tout
on était très voiture nous voilà voilà
voilà voilà pour la revente de break la
voiture on a eu de très joli retour de
tournage en voiture
[Musique]
un message de la prévention routière
pour pas inciter les gens à un baiser au
volant parce que ça peut être très
dangereux n'étions pas au volant alors
allons-y mes enfants qui conduisait pas
papa nous y avait du monde à lyon ne
sait plus lamentable eh oui c'est comme
ça salomé vous êtes la fille de claude
lelouch et d'evelyne bouix et vous avez
grandi avec pierre arditi qui était donc
marie d'evelyne à ce moment là vous avez
débuté au cinéma à l'âge de douze jours
votre mère savait ce que ça coûte de
quitter l'école trop tôt et elle nous a
interdit de le faire
c'est pierre qui m'a interdit de le
faire ouais c'est pierre qui au moment
où j'ai voulu partir de l'école à 16 ans
m'a dit non non maintenant tu ramènes
ton cul à l'école et tu passe son bac
c'est un bon père ce qui est rare dépit
quand même un très bon et ce qui est
dans l'intimité comme quand il vient
dans cette émission était toujours c'est
lamentable
voilà il le dit aussi bon on pensait que
ça nous était réservé mais non bon il le
dit tout le temps dit il le fait bien
c'est lamentable
on accueille maintenant jean luc
reichmann
[Musique]
jean luc reichmann bonsoir bonsoir donc
quelques mails jean-luc avant de
commencer un mail d'étienne mougeotte
vice président de tf1 où vous animez
tous les jours attention à la marche à
12h05
jean-luc si tu fais plus de 30% de parts
de marché sur les 15-35 cher 10 ans tu
es viré il le dirait jésus fait 15
bourses en parle un peu comme ça a créé
plus de 3% et je suis sûr etienne que
nous les fros jean-luc était une voix
des guignols donc effectivement c'est
imiter tout le monde alors c'est vrai
que etienne mougeotte lui même n'arrive
pas à savoir qui et fontaines etc et
bataille je ne sais pas alors fontaine
je ne boirai pas de ton nom c'est vrai
que le prochain grand prime time de tf1
c'est 100 meilleures émissions de
best-of des meilleures émissions
produits battures bien sûr
bien sûr bien jean-luc reichmann vous
avez déclaré je voulais être coluche
mais c'était déjà pris comme boulot donc
voilà on va essayer de prendre le boulot
de guy lux
non non j'ai là j'ai animé jeux sans
frontières
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai une saison
c'était un bonheur et là je me suis
senti vraiment guy lux ouais gibbs c'est
une langue à renoncer à vivre avec ça
fait bien sûr charaabi bonsoir chers
amis bonsoir et bienvenue à tout le
monde en parle
ah ouais c'est un bon ville ouais allait
passer commande
les finesses aussi non mais la callas ou
égal à huy sabri galabru et jean
rochefort
galloway non mais on n'est pas là pour
faire on n'est pas là pour faire patrick
sébastien sur l'a2 a down ou patrick
sébastien génial génial
et puis patrice qui est bien c'est qu'il
fait très bien serge gainsbourg à zeste
de citron c'est génial alors jean luc
reichmann vous avez découvert votre don
très tôt donc puisque votre père était
directeur de supermarché et un jour
c'est l'anniversaire du magasin il vous
met à l'animation de la vente de
saucisses vous fait un carton oui votre
premier carton 4 tonnes en cinq jours
cape town c'est un fait ça c'est
tranquille dans les bronzés faisais ça
aussi alors vous fait vos débuts
d'animateurs la radio en 81 ans 87 vous
venez à paris alors votre carrière bon
et la radio il ya des voix il ya plein
de trucs et du théâtre au sida
d'ailleurs jean est venu c'est une des
rares personnes qui soit venu c'était
une comédie musicale rock arrive la
maman est venue c'était les précieuses
ridicules de molière le texte était
intégrale mais c'était un roc musical
comédie et et c'est une des rares
personnes
elle était avec allain bougrain dubourg
ils ont eu un enfant
ouais m'avait blonde mais ça va pas ou
quoi c'est ma soeur dans sa boîte d'un
seul mandat de fond les blondes mais
amanda se doit ni glock n'a pas défendre
les blanc et noirs
je viens donc voilà votre carrière les
précieuses ridicules en rock'n'roll
entre autres des voix de la radio sur
les plus grandes chaînes de radio
nationale mais en fait vous devenez
célèbre jean luc reichmann dans
n'oubliez pas votre brosse à dents ça
dans seulement dans part en part voilà
et c'est là où moi j'ai découvert jean
luc reichmann le deal en fait avec nagui
c'était je veux bien faire ta voix off
mais je parle quand je veux celui qui
m'a laissé le micro ouvert souvient un
peu comme ma fille ici quoi oui oui et
ça a été ça a été un non mais moi je le
remercierai jamais assez c'est gonflé ce
coupé au montage comme ta gueule bien
intervenir quand vous vouliez ouais mais
ça c'était un grand bonheur il y avait
l'homme qui fait les samplers ici didier
de russan qui était juste a mal aux
enchères samedi à lille y envoie à
sampler pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est un super grand souvenir avec jl
didier se rappelle pas si c'est si je
pense sincèrement alors ensuite je vais
présenter d amour toujours sur france 2
et alors là évidemment il ya il ya un
truc énorme dans les z'amours j'imagine
qu'on vous en parle toujours le plus
rire dans la vie c'était quel est
l'endroit le plus torride où vous ayez
fait l'amour
1 donc le mari répond tu connais la
formule d'abord c'est le mari qui répond
la femme est cachée de marie répond sur
la table de la cuisine et la femme
répond on est dans la nuit
posh bisous il ya eu des trucs
extraordinaires il ya la bonne femme qui
voit son mec un jour à l'écran et elle
était partie sans laisser d adresse
depuis deux ans ça y est des histoires
extraordinaires mais c'est pas ça c'est
que c'est que ça en fait
à la production on reçoit un coup de fil
et dur enfin voilà bonjour excusez moi
j'ai vu une personne que je connais bien
et que j'aime j'aimerais bien rencontrer
tout ça il est passé hier dans notre
émission en diffusion
effectivement ils étaient en couple mari
et femme et en fait c'était le mari
d'une femme qui avait disparu depuis
deux ans et le mec est venu sur le
plateau avec une autre et je hais et on
n'avait jamais donné l'adresse mais
c'est c'est arrivé cette année il s'en
est passé des choses mais alors un jour
jean luc reichmann en 1999 on découvre à
l'antenne cette tache de naissance sur
votre visage qui avait été jusque là
dissimulé soigneusement par les
maquilleuses et en fait vous déclarez à
ce moment-là il bigot m'a demandé de
choisir entre eux la tâche et les ponts
john oui vous avez choisi la tâche
bah oui comme ça j'ai plus de pompes
john oui non mais c'était pour faire un
pied de nez parce que c'est vrai que au
début lorsque j'ai commencé la télé on
m'a conseillé
de rentrer dans un espèce de deux ans ya
beaucoup de tâches à la télé et paray et
donc
et donc voilà j'ai décidé d'être moi
même et puis c'est tout et pour l'avenir
sexy non en fait oui parce que en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que j'ai vu
jusqu'ici
quand j'ai vu cela non jumeaux ce qui se
passait avant ce qui se passait c'est
que quand vous sortez dans la rue non
maquillée dès janvier mais elle regarde
et tout donc vous avez décidé de vous
montrer à l'antenne mais comme dans la
rue oui c'est assez courageux je trouve
ces gentils non c'est vrai mais ça vous
pose pas de rien du tout non mais je me
suis je me sens bien on peut l'enlever
maintenant au laser il ya plein de ya
plein de possibilités et je veux pas
l'enlever je suis né comme ça et j'aime
mon rôle comme ça tu vois toi quoi moi
savoir
mais j'ai pas de tâches moi non mais
perd du terrain
laser justement récemment pour un grand
tatouage on s'appelle charlène les
coutures maintenant bon jean luc vous
savez qu'ici on dit tout dans quel objet
de tous passés en revue il ya aussi
votre petit dérapage
oui vous en souvenez de st oui très bien
raconté où je le raconte à vous le
raconter un jour comme ça il ya
quelqu'un qui gagne et vous dites bravo
ça fait 3 youpi pour patrick et vous
rajouter non ça fait 3 [ __ ] bon voilà
c'est le dérapage c'est le jour avancé
après vous dit j'espère que les [ __ ]
m'en voudront pas c'est là où c'est
devenu un peu grave n'ont même pas du
tout en fait ce qui sait pas ce qu'il se
passe quand on fait des jeux télé comme
ça vous le savez je m'appelle reichmann
avec deux n inquiète pas tout va bien et
donc quand on fait 50 ou 60 émission les
unes à la suite des autres on en fait 6
quand on fait des jeux comme ça je
faisais les allemands lors des six par
jour
j'étais fatigué j'en étais à la 55e 56e
il ya un jingle km et youpi youpi et
donc est donc j'ai enchaîné au niveau
des sonorités et c'est un très très
mauvais jeu de mots il s'avère que ils
ont oublié de le couper au montage
c'est tout simple et j'avais demandé
qu'on le coupé cela n'a pas été coupée
et quand on est fatigué on peut faire
des dérapages et c'en est un je me suis
excusé je sais le lendemain et juste
pour la petite histoire
c'était assez touchant pour moi parce
que c'est vrai que c'est une énormité on
en dit on en fait je me suis excusé a
juste avant mon émission le lendemain je
vous allez à la direction de la chaîne
j'aurais dû excusez moi c'est un très
mauvais jeu de mots je m'en excuse pour
de vrai je rappellerai chemin équipe
usée donc avec tous mais tous mes
ascendants est juste pour la petite
anecdote il ya un monsieur un joueur qui
est arrivé lors d'une conférence de
presse et qui m'a dit j'ai vu ce que tu
as fait et tu es la seule personne qui
ait eu le courage de faire ça avant une
émission le lendemain et depuis je te
regarde totalement différemment et j'ai
beaucoup de respect depuis ce jour là
pour alain delon parce que c'était alain
delon qui me l'a dit et me dit mais
ils n'ont pas compris que tu t'appelais
reichmann et j'ai été très touché par ce
match l'affairé close alors texte vous a
remplacé aux amours mais vous le trouvez
comment
très très sympa un connard ses hobbies à
main non non non non j'ai croisé mais
pas du nom mais c'est un autre style
c'est je suis inquiet
il sait très bien il est très bien dans
d'autres dans ce rôle là jamais présenté
et alors ça m'a beaucoup amusé l'ère de
la présente et pourquoi pas présenter
après mais facilement pas voulu je n'ai
pas jeté passait bien
à oui c'est toi oui toi moi les autres
aux jeunes attention c'est quoi le micro
de j'adore le micro d'un mandat c'est
parce que je suis dans le saint coran
givet
et là car d'internet laurent intervient
enfin on va faire le 18 à chaque fois
lors bien et l'a donc cher jean luc
reichmann nous inventer attention à la
marche
en fait france 2 n'en veut pas et vous
allez le faire sur tf1 oui avec beaucoup
de succès et je crois que c'est bien
mais maintenant ça marche bien je suis
très bien et ça marche bien alors
l'émission est basé sur des sondages
étonnant par exemple 27% des femmes m
enlever les points noirs de leur
conjoint combien de % de 7%
écoutez un trait qui m'avait vachement
étonné ckeck c'était quoi la question
sur sa femme combien de femmes d ont
déjà dans leurs vies déchirées les
habits de leurs hommes
ouais combien mal à combien combien tu
dis toi 16%
non mais ben non c'est combien non mais
j'avais dit 90 est en fait cédé 30
environ mais c'est vachement la france
et non comme une fille pas dû gagner par
rapport à celle relâchée à hambach et
fille mais c'est le décolleté reichmann
psychologue
vu d'ici c'est l'intello
prêter d'argent mais tu peux pas animé
tu commences tu m'avais pas dit s'ils
sont dégueulasses
une autre s'est par exemple combien
d'hommes porte un string tous les jours
at on avait 14 % non 1% excuse moi toi
tu vois des mecs qui sont pas normaux la
whey combien combien de filles
pratiquent la fellation c'est pas de 39
pour 60 cents larbi des districts
tribaux 9 % des français pensent que les
trains roulent plus vite la nuit par
exemple son ca extraordinaire c'est moi
je pense que ça aussi je fais partie je
pensais que les trains de nuit où les
pubs à huy avait personne sur les bois
qui m'intéresse vraiment bien son
bouquet ya plein de trucs à des fins de
savoir mettre un préservatif avec la
bouche
ah oui tu sais le faire ça en fin
d'émission
68% des français pensent qu'il faut pas
tout dire à leurs conjoints 68%
ça fait beaucoup quand même voilà et
vous pensez qu'il faut tout dire à son
conjoint quand ça fait mal non je pense
pas je pense que effectivement on peut
ne pas tout dire ne pas mentir mais pas
ceux d'hier mais justement on va faire
une interview et vous j'en rêve
[Musique]
trussant on t'a fait des compliments
tout à l'heure on a chanté ses louanges
essaie de nous envoyer un jingle qui
bave pas comme ça
[Musique]
alors jean luc reichmann 10% des hommes
aiment les femmes aux seins siliconés
c'est dans votre livre
et vous je dois vous avouer
qu'aujourd'hui je suis allé au salon de
l'agriculture
oui j'aime bien naturel 8% des hommes ne
portent pas de sous-vêtements ce qui est
mon cas d'ailleurs alors il vous portez
des sous-vêtements
oui l'été de temps en temps 54% des
français se sont déjà cogné la tête
contre le mur en faisant l'amour et vous
je roule en deux roues je porte un
casque 19 % des femmes ont déjà mesuré
le sexe de leur conjoint et vous senti
mon ami parce que je trouve ça
extraordinaire non moi je me suis jamais
fait rien du tout et vous et mesurer le
sexe de votre femme non et vous moi je
veux le court j'étais jeune nation on
peut jouer à ça bien sûr entière 1-1
s'est pas aventuré
quand j'étais étudiant à montpellier oui
il ya une femme qui vous êtes déjà
mesurer leur ont joué à ça bien sûr bah
oui côtoyé alors combien
alors je sais
vous voulez
j'aime vidéo impulsion ne pas avoir
honte voilà bien sûr c'est génial a plus
et moines et d'expansion marche pas
discuté de la moyenne
on va les caméras va nous dit jeudi avec
85 % des hommes justement pensent que
leur sexe et de la bonne taille et vous
avez très bien
ah oui ça va les gens assis ça c'est
intéressant à ces sports sont des hommes
sont dérangés par les cris excessif de
leur partenaire et vous savez est arrivé
une fois c'est horrible away à waimes
journée gêné 10% des français font
l'amour tous les jours et vous savez
quoi je suis en forme tous les ménages
ah ouais je retourner pendant les
vacances ce kit
c'est
marielle est trop tard
sardou same as roma risque reste mais ça
va ce qui aurait selon vous avez reçu
ici pour votre premier roman qui
s'appelle pardonnez nos offenses le
livre venait de sortir et depuis vous en
avez vendu 280 mille exemplaires et
s'est traduit dans 10 pays
il est content votre père mon père est
très content oui c'est bien ah oui c'est
bien c'était fin j'étais le premier
surpris je pensais pas je me doutais
qu'on allait en parler évidemment ou
qu'ils allaient avoir un petit un petit
coup de projecteur dessus pour des
raisons externes à la littérature mais
enfin bon on en vend pas 280 mille
exemplaires parce qu'on est le fils de
michel
non non les gens étaient contents donc
je suis ravie je continue
votre père dites-vous il à plus
d'imagination que le feu secrète oui on
associe le feu sacré à la scène plutôt
ça m'a pas ça n'a jamais n'avance pas
non
alors vous savez que votre père on l'a
souvent invité dans cette émission on a
même eu son smoking en vente
bon il veut venir lâche t il n'est pas
venu pour rien qui nous en veut mais
j'en sais rien je vais lui demander
devrait parvenir sa réponse on sait rien
non mais il fait pas beaucoup beaucoup
de télé est un art n'est pas rée des
nouvelles us mais fier de vous un peu
quand même
vous avez des nouvelles de lui a batu le
temps anciens bons à faire une interview
vous avez des nouvelles
[Musique]
est ce que il regrette toujours le temps
béni des colonies
le temps béni des colonies non je pense
pas mais il n'a jamais regretté un c'est
un petit bijou un personnage dans cette
chanson oui c'est pas parce que quand il
chante je suis pourri pense aux strings
pour homme cinq points je pense pas et
ce qui fait toujours l'amour en chantant
toujours d'ivoire et de son statut faire
mais c'est l'unique sur le s qui forgent
toujours la gueule dans les bals
populaires ou bien et préfère saint
tropez maintenant à noyers plus belles
populaire à saint tropez en pas trop tu
veux toujours pas qu'on l'appelle france
toujours il aime toujours les ricains
nom de moins en moins ouais ouais il a
été il n'était pas trop bon ça c'est une
longue histoire mais non il est
américain pour ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont fait comme tout le monde est
complètement con interdire tout mélanger
mais sur le sur le final et d'ailleurs
il n'y va plus ils allaient tout le
temps les états unis veulent ils avaient
toujours en france suffisamment la
france beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on dit
non tu es beaucoup encore ça il se corse
is beaucoup ça doit être l'âge est ce
que il pense au sida quand il dit elle
court elle court la maladie d'amour
il y pensait pas à l'époque en tout cas
c'était pas d'actualité pour ce qui
viendra un jour dans cette émission j'ai
des doutes quand même ah oui oui c'est
pas si je pense pas qu'il sera à l'aise
en ce jour de mai bon j'ai pas répond à
sa place mais je pense pas que c'est pas
trop pas trop son truc
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir ça va tu raques un peu
un petit peu c'est normal chope à tout
va bien je suis d'être là je suis ravi
que vous soyez là alors vous êtes la
fille cynthia de la première épouse de
michel sardou françoise pétré qui à
l'époque était danseuse au châtelet vous
êtes né en 1973 en même temps que romain
sardou nous avons reçues souvent ici
alors à l'époque où vous n'essayez donc
de l'épousé de michel sardou romain
n'essaie de babette qui à l'époque
n'était pas encore la femme n'était pas
encore la deuxième femme de michel
sardou
mais était sa maîtresse et sa moins
d'écart voilà voilà
alors michel voulait un garçon est de
toute évidence c'était pas vous c'était
pas moi c'était pas moi et je pense que
bon je l'est
comment expliquer sa décision mon père
j'étais une erreur quoi oui je le pense
sincèrement et je d'ailleurs je n'ai pas
honte de ce que j'ai écrit je n'ai pas
honte de ce que je suis aujourd'hui
parce que je suis une fille et je suis
ravi d'être une fille tellement parce
que les garçons à l'époque voilà voilà
excusez moi et alors votre mère vous en
à votre mère vous on a voulu en fait
parce qu'elle a la pensée elle s'est
imaginé que le fait que vous soyez une
fille à aider michel à se séparer d'elle
en fait elle faisant un petit peu rendu
responsable on est persuadé on est
toujours persuadé aujourd'hui oui oui
oui parce que j'ai d'ailleurs il ya une
lettre qui me le prouve justement et que
je que je que j'intègre dans l'histoire
donc effectivement je même trente ans
après vous voyez c'est visiblement cessé
rester êtes-vous donc j'avais grandi
avec ce sentiment de culpabilité
c'est à dire que vous vous sentiez un
petit peu responsable de la rupture
je me suis complètement sentir
responsable de cette rupture déjà parce
que j'ai
j'ai pas vécu je peux pas dire que j'ai
eu une enfance parce que j'en ai pas eu
mon père a effectivement donné ce qu'il
fallait pour notre éducation en revanche
moi je n'ai je ne me pense je ne
considère pas avoir reçu l'éducation je
me suis éduquer tout seul je m'étais
créé un monde à moi dans ma tête
un monde merveilleux qui m'a permis de
résister absolument à tous c'est à dire
dans mon mental c'est mon mental qui a
fait que j'ai résisté à toute la
violence que que j'aime bien alors à
l'époque où vous naissez michel sardou
est en train de devenir une méga vedette
vraiment une star nationale est en fait
vous décrivez l'envers du décor c'est à
dire que par exemple dont il est très
sympa comme ça que tu avec des gens et
quand il à la maison mais un cendrier
déplacer il rentre dans une colère noire
il lance des regards absolument terrible
aux gens enfin c'est willy ley il est
comme ça après son divorce
michel sardou épouse babette donc sa
seconde épouse et votre mère épouse
dites-vous un pseudo producteur de
musique que vous ne que vous ne citez
pas vous donnait pas son nom et lui est
intéressé en fait par les relations de
votre mère par le carnet d adresse de
votre mère par l'argent que votre père
versa votre mère mais en fait vous
l'appelez le funeste d'ailleurs ça sera
jamais quelqu'un de positif pour vous en
tous les cas
d'ailleurs je tiens président pour moi
il s'agit bien là criminels en liberté
c'est pas aussi c'est un personnage
terry parce qu'il exige que vous
l'appeliez papa mais il vous bas et ils
vous battra pendant des années en fait
j'ai vécu
dans cet entourage pendant plus de 15
ans ouais donc quand vous vivez ça tous
les jours effectivement c'est un moment
il faut partir il faut s'en aller les
votes mer derrière ben visiblement non
elle est je dirais que ma mère était une
absente
une absente avec un grand a et il n'y a
pas je pense que quand on aime quelqu'un
l'amour parfois peut aller si loin qu'on
on en est un est aveugle de tout ce qui
se passe autour et je pense que oui et
là c'était un moyen un moyen pour elle
de le garder que d'accepter ce qu il
vous faisait subir en fait peut-être
qu'envoyer michel sardou ça se passe pas
mieux parce que vous voyez très peu mais
quand vous voyez par exemple une fois
vous avez 5 ans il est très dur avec
vous un jour vous refusé d'évacuer la
salle de bains et vous traite de tas de
merde quand même quoi c'est vrai c'est
vrai j'avais 5 ans et je me rappelle
c'est d'ailleurs c'est même étonnant
mais la psychanalyse à faire remonter
encore des choses à la surface parce
qu'on croit toujours tout est enfoui et
qu'on oublie mais en fait c'est en soit
ce et après ça il s'est pas excusé quoi
michel sardou s'excuse rarement général
alors les bons moments finalement c'est
avec votre grand mère jackie sardou
alors là ça se passe super bien à quoi
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de beau oui qui
a été très présente et d'ailleurs même
dans des contextes
je dirais complètement loufoque parce
qu'elle était elle à el alami le
scandale dans un restaurant un jour et
c'était très drôle finalement bon
c'était une femme exceptionnelle c'est
une grande dame c'est une grande
comédienne parce que je pense qu'on lui
a pas rendu hommage comme il aurait
fallu le faire et j'avais envie de le
faire et ça me fait bien plaisir non
alors ce qui est terrible pendant toute
votre enfance en fait c'est que le sujet
michel sardou chez vous êtes un tabou
c'est à dire qu'on n'en parle pas sauf
pour dire que c'est un abruti
ou alors quand il passe à la télé aux
arbres donc en plus vous vivez dans le
déni de votre père pendant toute votre
enfance et votre adolescence oui je dis
rond
on était on nous a fait aussi du
bourrage de crâne pendant très longtemps
et ça je le il faut être
il faut le dire aussi et donc
effectivement quand vous avez du
bourrage de crâne dans tout ça vous
il était fait c'est normal qu'elle a au
bout du compte vous lui dis bon ben ok
bah non quoi c'est effectivement ça peut
ça du jeu ça gâche les relations quoi
qu'il arrive je disais en commençant que
votre livre était extrêmement
bouleversant parce que vous vivez et
finalement dans cette maison où on
critique votre père sans arrêt quand
vous voyez votre père et vous traite de
tas de merde et pour vos 12 ans votre
beau-père vous roue de coups carrément
vous êtes complètement recroquevillé
tout ça donc à un moment évidemment on
est on sait très bouleversant cette
histoire on souffre pour vous quand vous
êtes dans l'incapacité de bouger
et quand vous effectivement vous êtes au
sol et que vous pouvez pas bougé pendant
un temps la seule arme qui vous restent
si votre esprit et c'est ce qui s'est
produit également dans la tentative de
meurtre hier que votre mental quand je
oui il reste que ça pour finalement
trouver pour garder pour rester en vie
c'est un instinct de survie est ce que
votre beau-père il boude bas parce que
vous recevez des copines en pantoufles
par exemple moi je me suis demandée
sincèrement ce que je faisais là je
recherche avait rien à faire là et c'est
logique vous partez un moment donné
parce qu'il n'ya pas y'a rien à faire
y'a rien à alors justement cynthia quand
vous partez pour pour faire des études
tout ça vous vous apercevez qu'en fait
le fric que michel sardou donne à votre
mère votre beau-père le garde pour lui
donc en plus j'ai même pas les moyens de
faire des études enfin vous êtes
complètement bloqué vous avouer je me
suis offert une année six points j'ai
voulu le faire
j'ai travaillé pour ça j'ai travaillé
pour payer mes études et finalement même
si c'était pas énorme j'ai fait ce que
j'ai pu
ouais tout simplement vous êtes
courageuse
bon c'est vrai et malgré tout un moment
vous pensez à vous suicider quand même
oui effectivement
et c'est un clochard cette souris paris
n'est pas un alcoolique mais sous la
halle et c'est formidable formidable
alors vous commencez à vous en sortir
nous commencer à bosser
jackie sardou vous faire entrer chez
daniel filipacchi comme maître d'hôtel
exit est sympa je filipacchi assez bien
tous très bien voilà on fait des petits
boulots des petits jobs vous commencez à
vous intégrer à la société
vous commencez à exister vous travaillez
à itélévision donc qu est une filiale
info du groupe canal plus et là un soir
voilà vous quittez vos quitté i
télévision vous rentrez chez vous et
dans le parking de votre immeuble
vous êtes carrément enlever
par trois matches j'étais suivi en
voiture et puis j'ai été enlevée dans ma
voiture
oui trois mecs qui vont vous violez
pendant deux heures on m'a enlevé et
séquestré avec un couteau bien sûr enfin
couteau est pas loin en tout cas
et puis bon ben j'ai jeu et en plus je
sais même pas où on m'emmène je sais pas
ce qui va m'arriver
effectivement on peut s'attendre à tout
parce que quand on voit les visages le
visage d'un criminel et qu'on peut le
reconnaître
effectivement d'ailleurs j'étais à deux
doigts d'exploser dans mon auto donc oui
c'était alors à ce moment-là votre mec
vous lâche mais à un moment sardou pour
vous rejoindre à ce moment-là à un
accrochage dans le tunnel de la défense
et se brisent la mâchoire c'est vraiment
un enchaînement de choses absolument
absolument terrible et et vous vous
trouver refuge en fait chez michel
sardou qui vient de se remarier donc
pour la pour la troisième fois avec anne
marie périer vous commencez à vivre un
peu chez eux
c'est lui qui vous le propose en fait
tout à fait et au bout d'un moment il
vous le reproche
oui oui effectivement il ya un juste un
mois tout juste après les faits j'avais
quand même dans le sang
un traitement vih qui est quand même
difficile à supporter parce qu'en plus
j'ai repris le travail dix jours après
et je suis retourné à la chaîne j'ai
très bon j'étais en traitement
thérapeutique est effectivement j'avais
toujours dans l'est dans ma tête je me
demandais si j'allais avoir le sida ou
pas effectivement je
oui j'étais donc je travaillais à la
chaîne je rentrais le soir et tout ça et
puis effectivement il ya un bien
un matin j'ai été j'ai eu
effectivement une engueulade avec mon
père en privé et g
giro m'a foutu dehors quoi [ __ ] al
gore qui vous reprochent de squatter non
seulement son appartement mais sa femme
et puis dans ce cas pire que tout ce qui
vous dit que vous mangez du poisson et
que ça lui coûte plus cher que la viande
ça j'avoue que ça m'a complètement mais
je peux pas manger de viande c'est
impossible pour moi je ne pouvais pas
parce que suite au fait c'était
impossible sur et parce que je
je ne forçait pas jeu je me suis forcée
en plus de ça parce qu'il m'a quand même
fait manger de la viande
je ne dis pas mais c'est pas grave ouais
alors il vous dit que vous êtes nuls que
votre thérapie c'est de la merde enfin
vraiment on peut pas dire qu'ils qui
vous aide et ce qui est extraordinaire
dans cette histoire c'est qu'en fait
vous en auriez pas parlé on l'aurait
jamais su sire que tous les journaux
tous les magazines français les radios
les télévisions ont accepté de ne pas
parler de votre de votre viol est alors
lui en fait il va pas au procès
justement pour pas qu'on en parle des
nations je ne demandais pas à ce qu'il
soit là parce qu'effectivement la presse
aurait pu attirer il aurait pu attirer
l'attention de la base justement en
revanche un coup de téléphone ou un
petit mot gentil avec un bouquet de
fleurs ça fait de mal à personne
alors vos agresseurs sont condamnés à 15
13 et 10 ans de prison
ce qui est plutôt plutôt bien non plutôt
pas mal mais alors votre père qui a
toujours parlé de faire justice lui même
qui a toujours dit qu'il était pour la
peine de mort il à laisser la justice
faire son travail sans intervenir sur ce
coup là effectivement alors quelles ont
été les réactions de michel sardou à
votre livre il a eu une très bonne
réaction
il a très bien réagi à ça et c'est
plutôt agréable à entendre et je suis
ravi avec vaches dans l'air j'en sais
rien il a dit qu'il reconnaissait qu'il
n'avait pas été un bon père d'une
certaine façon en troisième
oui est ce que vous pensez pas que
michel sardou s'est comporté comme ça
avec vous parce que lui aussi a été
finalement il n'a pas eu ses parents il
était en pension moncel il voyait
rarement son père armand sa mère est
peut-être ça ne l'a pas habitué à être
un bon père d'une certaine façon non
c'est pas juan veut même pas d'avoir été
absent un mois je
parce que je ne lui en veux pas d'avoir
été absent parce qu'un artiste déjà ne
se comporte pas comme quelqu'un de
normal c'est pas quelqu'un de normal un
artiste un artiste c'est quelqu'un à pad
à part différent des autres qui est qui
reste dans une eau qui qui est solitaire
et donc je ne lui en veut pas d'eux
d'avoir été absent parce que je sais
qu'il a donné ce qu'il fallait donc je
lui en veux pas pour ça d'ailleurs je ne
lui en veux pour rien moi je suis parti
et je j'avais des raisons très
personnelles de le faire et d'ailleurs
j'ai écrit ces témoignages parce que
j'ai eu d'autres pressions aux états
unis et que j'en ai eu assez
mais quelle pression je vais aux états
unis des coups de fil désagréable et
j'en ai pas ce que j'avais écrit ce
témoignage au départ pour moi et j'en ai
eu assez de supporter parce que tout ça
ça fait remonter la peur et mon passé et
j'en ai eu assez je me suis dit que les
gens avaient le droit de savoir
ouais c'est tout vous l'avez vu caen
pour la dernière fois michel sardou je
l' ai vu il ya deux ans et demi c'était
juste avant mon départ aux états unis
ouais pas de plus au théâtre toujours
d'ailleurs j'ai ici et vous a téléphoné
depuis l'apparition du livre non vous
pensez que ce livre va aider ou à graver
votre relation avec lui déjà il n'y a
pas de relation pour l'instant donc il
n'ya pas de dialogue
effectivement et d'ailleurs je ne
cherche pas en avoir
moi j'ai fait un choix je suis parti
parce que c'était la seule façon de m'en
sortir
maintenant je vous dis sincèrement que
si je continue à être embêté là-bas et
si on continue
je vais pas non plus pousser loin les
pressions mais j'irai jusqu'au bout
vous regrettez pas de pas lui avoir dit
tout ça de vive voix plutôt qu'à travers
un livre à votre père j'ai essayé de le
faire plusieurs fois et ça il n'y a pas
de dialogue le dialogue ne passe pas je
les aime mes parents je les relis pages
remis personne sauf que il ya un moment
il n'y a plus il se passe rien qu'est ce
que vous voulez faire
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire je veux
dire il n'ya pas il n'y a pas d'issue
vous pouvez pas changer les gens
monsieur le ministre le mot de la fin
on cherche un peu un peu gêné par don de
vous le dire parce que je crois que dans
les affaires privées vraiment quand il
s'agit de la vie des couples la vie
amoureuse des gens la vie affective avec
ses parents personnes non seulement ne
peut juger mais personne n'a le droit de
juger on peut pas dire qu'on dise des
vérités ya pas de vérité dans ces
affaires là quand des gens sait pas
quand des gens se fâchent entre parents
enfants 36 proches que ça entre mari et
femme personne n'a le droit ni le
pouvoir de savoir ce qui s'est passé
vraiment et donc je suis au fond ce que
vous dites là il faut probablement cet
avis que vous le dit d'ailleurs mais
foliaire votre père peut-être à votre
analystes mais au fond je faciaux qui
est vraiment du courage à le publier
puis je suis pas sûr que ce soit bon
pour vous voilà mais bon il ferait on
parlait un peu plus longuement mais dans
ces affaires-là ne croyez pas que
personne ne pense qu'on puisse dire il
est mauvais il a tort il a raison la
pauvre où le haut le méchant on peut
jamais savoir comment ça se passe
peut-être que ce que vous dites est
entièrement vrai mais de toute façon moi
je ne le saurai jamais personne ici ne
pourra jamais juger et nanti peut-être
sont des choses qu'il faut le dire à lui
mais pas mais pas aux autres et donc je
fais toujours un peu gêné quand la
sphère privée s'étale en public alors
que bon voila vous livrer sa
au chien si je puis dire à des gens qui
vont le dire du mal de lui dira c'est un
sale autres mais personne n'en saura
jamais rien ici oui mais c'est votre
affaire avec lui et soule il faut régler
ça avec son père mais pas avec les
océans sardou est très secondaire dans
mon histoire
quand enfin si ce n'était pas lui on
n'en parlerai pas ici simplement que
j'ai vraiment peur qu'en passant du très
privé comme ça au public vous soyez
extrêmement déçu après parce que le
jugement des autres a probablement aucun
rapport avec ce que vous avez vécu en
tout cas n'attendez pas de qui comprenne
forcément ce que vous disiez ou qu'ils
puissent être jugeant l'affairé c'est
vrai que quand on écrit un livre et
qu'on le déchirent pas après c'est quand
même qu'on a besoin d'eux des autres
pour comprendre pour juger ce qu'on a
vécu quand c'est des affaires très
privée je crois qu'on risque d'être de
se tromper d'être déçu voilà c'est ce
qu'à ça je voulais vous dire sur tout
mais pas ses points méchanceté vous
répondre simplement que le crime n'a pas
de visage et que quel que soit le
contexte social vous vous soyez le crime
arrive n'importe où n'importe quand et
qu'il n'y a pas de lieu est en revanche
il n'y a pas de
mais tout peut arriver dans une
existence tout est possible et rien
n'est impossible dans le cours d'une
existence et c'est ça le message
et maintenant voici marilyn manson
vous voulez qu'on fasse rentrer mon
invité sur un an c'est une réaction par
rapport à certains emails qu'on a reçu
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas des puristes
on n'est pas forcément des linguistes
mais des gens qui sont irrités derrière
leur poste parce qu'il nous arrive
parfois de fans surtout à toi d'akerys
que moi je suis pas là serait souvent il
nous arrive de faire des fautes de
lâcher son nom je m'étais yoda mon
maître qui va être là juste pour
contrôler que les tournures
l'emplacement saison correcte avec human
comme le maître capello taux de 6
[Musique]
capello le rendu des services dedans
le temps
benoît
et c'est maintenant
la mairie qu'ils aient vu c'était aux
folies bergères on faisait double jeu
j'en ai fumé un pétard ensemble après
les après l'émission ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup à la moi ça m'étonne pas du
tout hein alors simplement maître
capello est là pour un peu supervise
sont tenus les belles construction de
phrase et puis faire la chasse me la
chasse aux barbarisme et au foot en
général d'accord mère d'accord
d'ailleurs je veux soutien des grains se
vouent vrai procès le 23 avril sans
liaison vrai c'est vous qui avez raison
à ce que je vous dit 3 avenue la liaison
oui mais dans 3 avril appsteur versa
dans la région
bonne idée
pour la semaine dernière
donc déchiré ses lettres de mécontents
il a arrêté la dope apparemment vous
avez arrêté les oies besoin de juin
d'accord très bien m bien vous restez
avec nous donc et si elles sont
utilisées
c'est tout instant
score sur un but
perez
bien tu vas voir à quel point il est
précieux
donc je vais être un petit peu la
dompteuse demain c'est à dire que c'est
une chanteuse
et mâts zuccarello la fille décide
vraiment devenir une arme mais vous
savez de quoi ai-je pas quand même c'est
sait rien on collectionne pas d'accord
oui pour montrer qu'on s'en fout quoi
non pas du tout une [ __ ] dominé set
que je maîtrisais irakien et la robe
peut en tout cas aider beaucoup
d'associations humanitaires des
parfaitement bilingue et elle est
parfaitement bilingue mairie du
simplisme à ce qu'on met en marche tout
cela
le mourre irak bien dire le rivage
oui ces derniers payent à ce prix j'ai
le peuple me répétant très bien merci
d'abord les zappings lundi quand ça
gagne est que du oui rivages de quoi qui
grippe la mésopotamie c'est entre les
deux fleuves parce que mes os et le
milieu potamot seillière fait entre le
tigre et l'euphrate israël break
confort et les services que lui car
avant mon pote à l'anus un resto c'est
bien connu le bihan nombre tout vous
dire le petit alors il est grand à le
bihan ça veut dire le petit détail
décrypte tous extraordinaires est normal
ouais
et oui ça veut dire quoi rouve ouf c'est
le cher groupe c le chat doué ou quoi
leroux française classique en gaulois et
du gaulois par maître marc italien ouais
c'est bien tu imagines là le petit nom
de scène à côté de l'autre alors samuel
avant de parler du film qui vous amène
ici j'aurais quand on revienne quelques
instants à la case départ qu'on fasse
une espèce de données pas un espèce très
bien mais je sais maintenant une espèce
de ce fait bien parce que je m'attendais
dans le pied
un peu oublié soit responsable yéménite
invité surprise de bâti donc on est
obligé je fasse un pas deux fois en plus
de français g ii you s'est excusé moi
met bien non mais vous avez déjà fait de
la boxe toute façon avant la manif un
ouais on mesure j'en ai fait un petit
peu oui j'aimais ça ouais mais là
j'étais coachée par stéphane ferrara si
tout est passé c'est bien d'un grand nom
mais laurent lemay sur pouce de temps en
temps mais le problème c'est qu'ils se
démarquent tout seul ou pas la route
comment dans quelles catégories car la
ml2d bonnabaud j'ai des poids moyens et
il va le marché s'intéresse à tout il
faut lui dire j'ai fait rage qui m'ont
tué et toitures en janvier jeux de mots
bas protège
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille manson
bonsoir vous parliez de drogue tout à
l'heure je n'ai même pas encore arrivé
bonsoir marilyn donc vous appelez
marilyn comme monroe et manson comme
charles manson
ça vous est venu comment cette idée
d'accoupler le nom d'un tueur en série
satanistes avec le prénom d'une icône
glamour de l'amérique
je voulais être la meilleure
représentation possible de l'amérique
votre surnom ses entés christ superstar
c'est bien que vous en pensez preuve est
hantée christ superstar
c'était le nombre d'albums la relève est
assurée et marilyn manson est une star
donc du shock rock ce qu'on peut appeler
le shock rock alors dans la tradition de
badis toons avec sympathy for the devil
ensuite il est black sabbath avec ozzy
osbourne alice cooper les sexpistols je
suis un artiste je suis l'antéchrist
chantait johnny rotten alors on est très
contents de vous avoir ce soir parce que
vous êtes une star mondiale marilyn
juste hier il ya un e-mail qui va nous
tomber beaucoup de gens règlent leur
téléviseur tout ça est normal
peut-être que les gens croient qu'ils
regardent deux chiens de la fois une
faim de lloret maître capello in china
et lehman n'a pas du tout c'est la même
chaîne c'est france 2 bien on va
commencer par le début manson vous êtes
né le 5 janvier 69 et votre vrai nom
c'est brian hugh warner votre père était
un ancien mécanicien d'hélicoptère au
vietnam mais je me trompe jamais moi et
oasis américaine monde
il gérait une magasin de meubles art et
il est seul moment d'intimité de votre
père avec vous c'était quand ils vous
emmener au stand de tir pour vous
apprendre à tirer ça c'était un vrai
moment d'intimité avec lui et puis aussi
il vous emmener au concert de kiss 1 à
12 ans mon père avait justement
maquillage qui s'est mal un concert dans
cette tenue
papa était cool ça c'est votre papa
votre maman celle inverse elle a été
très très possessive traître est
étouffante comme ça et quand vous êtes
petit marilyn manson vous passez
beaucoup de temps chez vos
grands-parents et vous découvrez la
sexualité dans la cave de votre grand
père voilà alors dans la cave du
grand-père à ça te plait ça jenna alors
dans la cave du grand père de marie
ligne avec quoi matri capello dans la
cave du grand père du matin
non il y avait des nazis y allait y
avait des lingerie féminine
il y avait des godemichés enduits de
vaseline les godemichés et puis elle
aussi des photos au fil à aillas est
assez juste oui c'est très drôle de
grand père notamment quand j'étais gamin
mon grand-père me paraissait monstrueux
mais en grandissant je me suis rendu
compte que mon grand-père était bon je
suis comme lui est pas si mal que ça
disons que je n'aime pas trop les
animaux spa les faits la zoophilie
ce qui n'a pas tiré un cheval lancé à
jeter la pierre j'aime boire
alors donc vous allez à l'école est
l'héritage christiane school à et là
évidemment mais j'arrive pardon parce
qu'il a aussi regretté donc je sens que
je m'en faire un mythe capello merci
mais en plus donc voilà vous avez dans
cette école donc pour vous inculque des
valeurs fondées sur l'antéchrist et sur
l'apocalypse alors évidemment ça ça se
travaille dans votre tête vous essayez
de vous adapter à l'école vous essayez
de vous adapter et un jour vous leur
apportez une photo c'est des nuages dans
le ciel qui représente un ange et lui
parce qu'ils pensent à un vous pensez
leur faire plaisir
c'était ma grand mère ils m'ont dit que
c'était un faux et donc c'est la seule
fois où j'essaie de m'intégrer de
redmond on savait qu'on m'a dit tout ça
c'était du bidon
j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté de croire ou des
c3 à ce qu'on racontait est alors au
lieu de vivre dans la peur
avoir des cauchemars qui plagie décidé
de devenir ce dont j'avais peur juste
mais voilà alors là c'est la révolte dès
l'âge de 12 ans vous vous révoltez vous
êtes attiré par tout ce qui est interdit
vous êtes à l'époque vous est maigre
vous êtes couvert de boutons vous êtes
toujours tout seul enfin vous avez une
adolescence ça c'est assez terrible en
moi je me sentais invisible et
transparence c'était page été rejetée
j'étais vraiment invisible on ne me
voyait pas et ça n'avait qu'à travers la
musique ou l'écriture quand j'étais
gamin je me suis dit je serai artistes
l'écrivain j'ai pensé que j'allais
chanter parce que je ne savais pas
chanter mais bon et c'est comme ça que
j'ai trouvé ma propre voie je crée mon
monde et alors là en compagnie d'un
certain john cromwell et de son grand
frère au lycée vous commencé à vous
intéresser aux sciences occultes aux eau
qu une bonne nuit et zoug
avant impôts de lacunes dans le noir
mais c'est bien parce que comme ça ça
cautionne et c'est le service public
service plus belle ses biens dont vous
intéresser avec ce dénommé john cromwell
aux sciences occultes aux doctrines
satanique 1 c'est l'époque où vous
visiter disneyland sous acide
deiss c'est à propos cette émission
rappelle un peu cet épisode un peu
surréaliste et là vous faites de la
scène donc c'est le scandale évidemment
vous masturber sur scène à un faux pénis
qui éjacule un liquide improbable vous
jeter des aéroports un accessoire dire
vous vous jetez des poulets vivants au
public mais c'est vrai que c'est le
public qui les égorge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
non
au sujet de votre cinquième album sur le
précédent vous avez déclaré
c'est l'histoire d'un innocent qui veut
faire partie d'un monde qui ne
l'acceptent pas il se bat il découvre sa
révolution et finit par devenir un objet
marketing
aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu un objet
marketing que je fais je l'exploité et
d'en faire ils ont une marchandise eh
bien il yal'affaire donc de colomb aille
donc cette université du michigan où
deux fans ouvrent le feu sur leurs
camarades et les médias américains vous
accuse alors vous répondez on peut pas
accuser shakespeare de pousser les gens
au suicide parce qu'il a écrit roméo et
juliette
enfin c'est vrai quand même que les gens
qui ont tiré sur leurs camarades étaient
des fans de marilyn manson accès en fait
il fallait un coupable
donc on m'a brandi un peu embêtant c'est
cette effigie du coupage et j'étais déçu
de ne pas répondre à tout cela parce que
je ne voulais pas justement donné les
alimenter cette flamme
les gamins voulait justement acquérir
une espèce de célébrités malsaine la
mairie fera à tenait justement ce qu'il
recherchait et je voulais pas y
contribuer donc on associe le nom
marilyn manson à cette horreur et en
fait marine manson est devenu le produit
de colombes a été ironiquement c'est
quand même assez injuste d'être attaqué
par vos progrès après détection à la
cantine et des actuels et il n'a pas
traduit vêtements pas réellement mais en
fait voilà la finesse vous dites que
cette histoire finalement permettait
d'oublier monica levinsky parce qu'à
l'époque c'était le grand scandale de
monica levinsky on oublie aussi grâce à
ça les bombes balancer sur le kosovo et
vous dites c'est moi qu'on accuse de
provoquer un comportement violent alors
que finalement à la même époque les
états unis bombardé la yougoslavie
absolue est exactement celle des seniors
au pot en dire autant de ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est à dire qu'on va
continuer à censurer les mots
les images ou mais où ma musique en fait
il ya un véritable duplicité du
gouvernement et moi mon rôle c'est
justement de mettre cette démarche défi
il faut que si l'amérique représente la
démocratie moi je dois représenter la
liberté de création
ce n'est pas quelqu'un comme moi n'y
aurait personne justement pour remettre
en cause les fausses idées ni à moi qui
irai que revient le rôle justement de
remettre en cause certaines politiques
certaines valeurs ce qui ne veut pas
dire que je déteste les jeux l'acceptent
parce qu'elle est mon rôle c'est en
faire un pays plus intéressant plus
divertissement en étant beau gosse
d'accord alors dans le film quand
michael moore vous pose la question et
vous dites qu'est ce que vous diriez au
lycée en colombie et vous répondez je
les écouterai ce que personne ne fait
rien c'est quelque chose que j'ai un
départ avant l'incident de koloma
n'était pas la première fois qu'une
telle tragédie se produise c'est pas moi
qui ai inventé la violence et c'est pas
non plus les gamins le colonel contamin
t la violence l'oeil du manager à cette
tendance
une tradition de s'autodétruire et ça
c'est quelque chose que j'ai toujours
évoqué dans ma musique alors c'est quand
même assez curieux qu'on me montre du
doigt parce que tout ce que je dis tout
ce que je chante c'est un commentaire ce
cette triste réalité et il est vachement
saget un onglet par les nantis
et maintenant
si mike horn
non
bonsoir bonsoir confort palais france et
maintenant comme une vache espagnole
or voilà donc mike horn est ce qu'on
appelle un aventurier de l'extrême c'est
un type extraordinaire la preuve il a
déjà descendu l'amazone à la nage
il a fait le tour du monde en suivant la
ligne de l'équateur
hélas hélas vous n'étiez 20000 km autour
du cercle polaire arctique
c'est la fameuse expédition arctos ce1
alors vous raconter ça dans un bouquin
qui est publié chez x o qui s'appelle
conquérant de l'impossible alors au
départ vous êtes d'origine hollandaise
c'est des hollandais qui sont partis
habiter en en afrique du sud les
français on a et on en est au rendez
vous oui pardon comme dave coles
mais il donne pas dans le même coin mais
bon pas trop doit alors votre père était
directeur de lycée c'était annexes
springbok il est mort quand vous aviez
15 ans et votre mère était enseignante à
leurs enfants vous étiez déjà très
sportif mike horn et son avenir de
d'aventuriers se dessine assez tôt à 8
ans vous rejoignez en vélo la ferme de
votre oncle qui est située à 300 km de
là 300 kilomètres séparent loi si tu as
du temps
[Rires]
il a commencé la drogue tôle alors quand
vous étiez adolescent vous êtes rentré
dans l'armée vous avez été capitaine des
forces spéciales sud-africaine effet la
guerre en namibie donc ça vous a
effectivement formé à la violence
voilà et puis ensuite vous rentrez dans
la vie professionnelle et la mike horn
est employé par son oncle il fait de
l'import export de fruits et légumes au
départ dire vous réaliser une
transaction exceptionnelle sur des choux
qui vous a rapporté énormément d'argent
moi j'ai trop vite trop bien gagner ma
vie mais voilà ça lui plaisait pas parce
que bon il avait plein de blé n'y avait
pas de but dans la vie est là vous
établissez il avait pas de but dans la
vie chaude
donc là vous établissez une liste des
endroits de la jungle des étendues
glacées ou vous aimeriez aller et puis
vous réunissez tous vos amis un jour oui
quoi j'ai eu tout ce que je voulais oui
mais c'était pas ça que je voulais et je
disais mais ce soir je fais un grand feu
de chez moi
et puis je viens d'acheter à
johannesburg un grand maison il y avait
une piscine et où je disais à mes potes
écoute vient et puis ce soir je donne
tout ce que j'ai à toutes mes potes et
puis on a bu un peu divers et tout ça ma
soeur est avec avocate elle après pas
préparé toutes les contraintes
je donnais tout à mes amis et puis je me
retrouvais avec un sac à l'aéroport il a
tout donné alors à ce moment là inconnu
à ce moment là mais ces expériences
m'ont live à l'aéroport et les seuls
pays en fait on pouvait aller quand on
était africain du sud sans visa c'était
israël la suisse et l'angleterre donc il
va l'aéroport à ce moment là y'a un
avion qui part pour la suisse c'est
comme ça que vous vous retrouvez à
zurich
exactement exactement 100 sans rien
connaître de la langue sans rien
connaître du pays
alors début c'était difficile quand même
vous voyez j'ai commencé il y à il ya
360 km entre zurich et montreux et puis
parce que j'ai pas eu du travail
oui j'ai pas eu l'argent j'ai décidé de
faire ça à pied puis de passer un peu
vers les paysans pour demander s'il y
avait du travail 1 puis c'est toujours
un peu la même réponse qu'à me disais
que quoi on n'engage pas des étrangers
1 et puis là je disais d'accord écoute
moi je continue à y arriver
j'arrivais à montreux j'ai commencé de
volée juste pour rester vivants vous
voulez des noms que vous avez volé des
fruits à wayne a il faut que j'ai dormi
dans des étapes j'ai dormi sous des
pantins c'est incroyable parce que il ya
quelque chose d'extraordinaire cirque en
afrique du sud
vous faisiez partie de la la classe des
possédants la classe des riches des
blancs à l'époque c'était la partie
et puis un jour vous arrivez en suisse
et vous retrouver dans la position du
noir que dans la position du du titre
capable parce qu'ils ont bien regardé
ans
ouais mais coûte c'est sûr c'est sûr que
si tu te trouve dans une situation un
peu que t'as pas vraiment l'habitude du
10 soit tous rentrer à la maison mais
est-ce que j'ai eus rien à la maison
jeudi
il faut que j'avais mes responsabilités
vous aviez comme on dit brûler vos
vaisseaux c'est à dire que vous n'aviez
plus de maison dans laquelle retournez
donc j'étais obligé de continuer vous
faites des petits boulots vous installez
ensuite vous rencontrer katy qui
deviendra votre votre femme vous
commencez à trouver des sponsors en face
et un courage absolument extraordinaire
et là vous vivez votre première grande
aventure en 1997 traversée de l'amérique
du sud à trois il part du pérou il fait
déjà 600 bornes à travers la cordillère
des andes mais comme ça tu vois les gens
comment il fait pour y aller au pérou en
avion ouais j'ai une copain qui était
pilote et puis voilà
il fait 600 morts dans la cordillère des
andes jusqu'aux sources de l'amazone et
là vous descendez l'amazone l'idée
c'était 6400 km à la nage
l'idée c'était dedans fait traverser
l'amérique du sud mais en solitaire sans
assistance
et puis il des bouées quand même il
avait un truc s'appelle l'hydrospeed
c'est une petite planche tu sèmes
bodyboard commandes et xelis comme ça
vous allez c'est les jambes des jambes
c'est des lycées des amis me demandent
aux élus
ja il ya un animal t'es pas mal
intéressant parce que tu peux pas
vraiment faire pipi dans l'eau parce
qu'il y avait cinq poissons de chats
mara site dès que tu fais pipi en fait
les urines cela tire je rentre et
sahraouis où il ya un trou ouais
et puis en fait tu peux pisser dans vos
mais il faut regarder ton patelin
c'est comme tu peu chier sur la place
vous qui fait quand même six ans il fait
quand même 6400 km à la nage donc avec
son hydrospeed pour descendre l'amazone
jusqu'à l'embouchure de l'amazone dans
l'océan dans le sens authentique ses
premières aventures d'isa pris six mois
deuxième grande aventure qui a encore un
exploit absolument unique
le tour du monde en solitaire par
l'équateur son véhicule à moteur à
l'idée c'était de rester sur l'équateur
et pas de m'éloigner plus 40 millions
d'euros à la ville au sud
et puis de deux parties d gabon et quand
vous quittez le gabon c'est la première
fois que vous vous retrouvez seul sur un
voilier ouais jamais j'ai jamais c'est
la voile en fait c'est gégé winch est un
fait sur des bateaux de laurent bourgnon
quels sont les grands gagnants il part
du gabon pour forcer l'atlantique
c'est la première fois qu'il essaye sur
un voilier alors ensuite bon il ya
l'amérique du sud vont traverser
l'amérique du sud l'indonésie avec les
révoltes avec le combat tout ça c'est un
cas extraordinaire et puis bon voilà
vous êtes élu aventuriers du xxème
siècle quand même ouaip avait par un
autre c'est quoi c'est pour ça bon on a
vu donc la descente de l'amazone à la
nage le tour du monde par l'équateur est
là en février 2002 sert klose donc c'est
la dernière expédition celle que vous
racontez dans votre bouquin conquérant
de l'impossible donc 20000km tour du
cercle polaire arctique
à contre courant et à contrevent alors
on les dit mais pourquoi quand on fait
vingt mille kilomètres autour du cercle
polaire arctique pourquoi vous le faites
à contre-courant à contrevent qu'il
s'entend si bien que cinq sa fin
et alors quand on lui dit pourquoi vous
le faites à contre-courant un contrat
dont il dit bah parce que en cas de
réussite dans l'autre sens
j'aurais passé toute ma vie à me
demander comment j'aurai réussi dans le
mauvais sens ça moi je la mettrais
d'échouer un peu contre 1 contre des
aliments que d'aller avec les années a
dit des trucs dit les c'est tellement
dur ce qui fait que trouvent le courage
de surmonter toutes les épreuves et vous
dites je les ai surmonter parce que
j'ignorais quelle souffrance elle
représentait si j'avais su qu'elles
souffrent j'allais vivre je l'aurais pas
fait vous utilisez des accessoires aussi
à la maison c'est bizarre on m'écoute
pas je crois j'ai pas du tout mal il ya
des moments qui est plus dur que les
autres
aujourd'hui cm c'est mon métier et puis
je fais ça professionnellement pendant
dix ans et puis c'est moi je vois ça
comme tout à fait normal qu'on fait les
courses au programme un caddie ou vous
mettez tout comme sa survie alors ce
qu'il faut savoir quand même c'est
qu'avant de faire le tour du cercle donc
voilà il ya l'envers il ya eu un voyage
préparatoire le voyage préparatoire il
dit bon pour me préparer ainsi pour se
mettre en forme
je vais aller au pôle nord en solitaire
800 morts c'est juste pour s'entraîner
juste pour s'entraîner et la grosse
erreur je n'ai pas eu vraiment choix
c'était un moment que je marchais plus
ça veut dire que mon corps génère plus
de chaleur et puis je commence de tomber
dans les po thermie oui et puis là c'est
la vie aux ligues lima 1
j'ai enlevé mes move pour attacher mes
chaussures là et puis c'est sûr c'est la
dernière fois que je m'enlève mmo je
vais là les doigts explose et alors ce
qu'il fait il rentre dans sa tente
il met ses doigts dans le feu parce
qu'ils sont tellement gelée qui les met
dans le feu et à ce moment là où il a eu
il a été un peu amputé oui et à ce
moment là et ça sent la viande brûlée
lui sans rien mais ça s'en va et ça sent
la viande brûlée alors effectivement là
vous décidé de rentrer donc cette
expédition préparatoire n'a pas été
menée
son terme décidé de rentrer pour sauver
vos mains en fait ce sera exactement à
un moment que tu dises mais là
maintenant je dois rentrer je dois
réparer mes mains non autrement si je
continue j'étais à quinze jours du pôle
si je continue je veux permet main et
puis je peux plus rien faire ne marche
tout ça parce que tu avais des céphalées
chroniques on marche pas à -50 sap est
en fait ça peut être bon sans compter
sur vous rentrez on vous ampute un peu
le bout des doigts mais vous attendez
même pas le délai normal vous partez
pour cette fameuse expédition donc
archos et là il ya des épreuves
absolument inouïe celui d'hier c'est par
exemple un moment il va en bateau au
départ de de norvège royal hollande il
ya un trou dans la coque est là alors là
c'est incroyable cirque d'une main et
conduit le bateau de l'autre ils vident
le bateau et les icebergs qui arrive sur
lui les mecs ils au milieu céline dion
qui se dit à dormir parce que s'il dort
il peut plus piloter le bateau peu plus
vide et le bateau donc voila et puis au
milieu des icebergs comme ça créatif dix
fois un peu on n'a pas vraiment les
choix du foie puis 1 si on va arriver à
défaut c'est vraiment un fou jouer à
chat [ __ ] ou quoi
alors après il traverse au groenland
il sera la seconde langue avec une
espèce de cerfs-volants quoi et ça va
très vite parce que vous arrivez à faire
d un jour par exemple il fait 18 heures
dans la journée 143 km donc ça va assez
vite vous battez le record de traversée
du groenland
grâce à ce système de cerfs-volants et
puis un jour il ya un vent énorme
looping voilà ouais vous êtes vous et
arracher j'étais arraché par une tempête
de vent exactement là c'était juste
moment que tu peut plus gérer la surface
est trop grande mais carey vivent sous x
60 70 kilomètres à l'heure et tu peux
plus de sont à voile c'est sûr qu'il ya
un moment que tu vas passer d'eux une
cravate tu vas passer d'un pote de
développement avec le professeur l'avait
fait là c'est sûr que tu tombes
il s'en sort à chaque fois c'est
extraordinaire à un moment il arrive
dans une région il doit prendre un
bateau pour la calamity belge croit il
doit prendre un bateau et puis bon il ya
la glace qui fait qu'on peut pas
naviguer
il fait un détour de 1200 km le mec avec
jets privés des tours de 300 m² sur 2200
km et tout ça à moins 60 dans la nuit
permanente parce qu'en plus de ça il
faut voir ce que c'est ça il fait même
pas jour il neige il fait froid moins 60
il fait nuit voilà malheureusement on a
trois mois de nuit ou n'a pas beaucoup
de soleil mais on aurait pu soleil sort
via bangkok 24 heures sur 24 et puis là
tu peux bien avancé alors c'est
extraordinaire parce que ce sont des
régions où la vie humaine est impossible
si rappeler celles qui vivent là-bas ce
sont les inuits
mais oui bouge pas il reste tu vas y
vivent sur leur graisse comme les ours
quoi ils vivent tout l'hiver sur leur
graisse afin qu'on en attendant qu'il
fasse beau et lui non lui il avance là
dedans dans ce pays donc même pas un
inuit qui qui fait ce que vous avez fait
quoi
c'est parce que les mises au point
compte déjà 1 et puis en plus les in
which has a
au début de l'hiver là et puis l'hiver
iris parce qu'il peut plus il voit rien
ouais
et puis moi si je restais je crève et
c'est là que j'ai été obligé d'un marché
en fait de rester vivant et alors mike
votre votre la tente dans laquelle vous
habite elle en quoi les îles et des
zones ils ont à traiter en fait que ça
brûle pas et puis en même temps les
problèmes c'est que tu as tu as quelque
chose à moi 50 que tu peux pas vraiment
plier parce que l'hymne ils ont au moins
50 en -60 situe le pli 2 3 fois sa
casque en hiver tout vient vraiment
cassant et qu'il a fait alors et puis là
tu dois faire vachement gaffe quand tu
mettes l'attend quand il fait vraiment
trop froid
tamer temps pas de la matraque de mme
éclatante et puis tu dois marcher un
fait reste pour rester vivants vous avez
quand même envie de faire pipi de temps
en temps écoute si tu la sors et quand
c'est pas évident alors parce que tu ne
trouves pas déjà fait si froid que ça
c'est les 5 litres de l'eau l'eau avant
dormir je bois 5 litres fait ça mais
permettent de réveiller chaque une heure
chacune heure et demie comme ça gèle pas
en dormant et puis je sais que je vais
rêver peut-être autrement tout content
de tout on dort en moi 50 au moins 60 il
ya si tu dors trop profondément
un fait que tu peux jamais tu vas jamais
rêvé tu vas j'allais se dit que la seule
façon de vraiment fier c'est d'avoir
envie pisser et puis la piste et en
bouteille 1
et puis parce que la piste est à 36
degrés oui je prends les bouteilles et
puis je chausse mes pieds parce que mes
pierre à l'extrémité les sacs de
couchage et vu des moteurs
je veux dire un truc quand tu lis le
bouc ah ouais je me suis dit c'est vrai
ce que tu dis parce que je me suis même
perdre tout est bidon un moment c'est
tellement énorme ce qu'il a vécu que tu
dis c'est pas ça jamais ça jamais été
faire pendant l'hiver et c'est
extraordinaire
et alors avait été chaude tutu savent
pas son intérêt aux attentes du peuple
en disant l'hiver si tu vas d'or tu veux
bcta pantalon et puis tu peux sortait
pts et 10 % un pirate tu veux mais tu
sais impossible d'exposer des petits
drapeaux tape au loin a dit y produire
au moins 5 ans témoin 60 se dit que tout
pas son intérêt relatant y avait une
trappe à l'intérieur attentes je pouvais
faire un petit trou voix couach yachts
son intérieur l'attend mais sans gel
tout de suite quoi ah oui c'est solide
comme ça tu n'aurais pas des animaux
alors c'est incroyable le pire de tous
et contient un incendie parce qu'à un
moment votre bouteille de benzin tombe
sur le sur le réchaud et alors là en
plein milieu de cette immensité glacée
et ultra froide
il ya un incendie et tout brûle quoi
c'est à dire la tante brûle tout brûler
il y a moi j'ai rempli j'ai mes
bouteilles mois 45
et puis un jour il y avait la taille
voiture ça a chauffé à -25 et puis à moi
vente il ya jusqu'à moi 45 il ya 25
degrés des différences
1 et puis là tu vois un peu difficulty à
commanditer histoire skis expansé puis
là parce qu'il fait chaud il fut
prenez-la volume et puis avec mon
réchaud de l'intérieur l'attend quand
j'ai ouvert
en fait mon bouteille ça gicle partout
s'agit qu'un peu sur moi c'est écrit sur
mon sac de couchage et en plein feu
l'implant plein milieu de de l'arctique
aux sextoys alors après mon jules pas
tout raconter mais c'est vraiment génial
il ya l'alaska le détroit de béring la
sibérie il fait tout le tour le mec est
alors parfois vous vous tombez pas ce
que votre corps refuse de
2 vous obéir et là vous avez la
tentation de ne plus vous relevez la
tentation de vous laisser mourir et si
vous entendez la voix de vos filles du
problème c'est que quand quand on
commence déjà les on sait vraiment pas
ce qui se passe avec nous et puis là
c'était après douze heures de marche
voyait nuages noirs qui arrive sur
l'horizon et puis je disais est ce que
j'essaie de marché à travers de ses
compétences
j'essaye de mettre attendent maintenant
et puis j'ai fait une erreur je disais
mais je veux marcher à travers parce que
je peux gagner peut-être cinq à dix
kilomètres
et puis là c'est sûr que la tempête a
pas arrêté pour trois jours il y avait
un moment que physiquement tu es tu
étais tellement fatigué la luge derrière
toi pays la cent cinquante à soixante
160 kg et puis à un moment que tu peux
plus tirer main et puis la conte niveau
remonte à 150 kilomètres à l'heure ce
niveau est venu du nord moi je marche
vers l'ouest ça roule en fête foraine
sur la glace et puis tu embarques avec
et puis là tu dis mais je peux me lève
et je dois encore ramasser un divan
je préfère de mourir parce que comme ça
je n'ai plus besoin tirer la juge je
n'ai plus besoin de faire quoi que ce
soit je peux crever ici il est vraiment
aller au bout le vaincu un répit et puis
on a une vie pépère finalement
oui
et
bravo merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
donc un choix heureux nous avons sur des
marques tu fais pas lui j'ai pris trop
traîneau dans le vide d'image ambiante a
pas été très surpris en fait par la
discipline de la première compagnie
parce que tu as été élevé dans une
pension anglaise en argentine où tu as
pris des coups 1
j'ai pas pris de coup j'avais dans le
règlement il y avait ce qu'on appelle
des punitions corporelles à c'était
normal si on a tous vu kif et une palme
d'or à cannes c'est fait ça fait partie
intégrante sauf que le règlement est
très précis quand on fait une connerie
rond c'est ce qu'on risque ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas est réglé donc tu
sais que quand tu rentres dans leur défi
par exemple ces vingt coups de canne en
tous les cas c'est dommage que tu es
quitté la première compagnie parce qu'on
était devenue la la mascotte des
téléspectateurs théron fle mentez douche
tout nu
c 'est les gens s'y réhabituer l'idole
des radiologues
oui oui l'idole des radios la wii 2
c'est ça nous appartient pas moi je ne
sais pas ce qui montre je ne sais pas ce
qui fait donc
et pourquoi est il devenu la bête noire
des autres parce qu'ils avaient peur
peut-être que j'aille en finale alors
que j'avais pas fait d'effort physique
ouais il te détester t'as vu en revenant
t'as vu les images tu as vu comment ils
te casser des chapelles à l'horizon
j'arrive pas alors à vouloir
ouais mais d'autres comme enfermés dans
un cercle fermé il y pensait tous à
gagner donc on gagne
ouais et aller alors que sait même pas
qui tu étais que c'est même pas que tu
avais joué dans un james et non plus
très bien à pas d'avoir vu dans votre
émission très loin je devrai pas très
bien ce serait là les frais dans ma vie
non plus c'est l'émission si vous avez
vos fils je n'ai jamais parlé de métier
pendant six semaines
jamais jamais raconter ma vie d'acteur
là bas oui mais les jours c'était beau
[ __ ]
pourquoi tu as fait la première
compagnie pourquoi je l'aurais pas fait
c'est un clin d'oeil à ton fils qui a
réussi grâce à la love story
je pense que benjamin n'a pas réussi que
grâce aux 900 il est devenu connu grâce
à l'aube story mais disons que ce qui
fait aujourd'hui où ce qu'il a fait
après prouve qu'il avait quand même un
potentiel suffisant pour réussir
benjamin aujourd'hui c'est mon fils
toujours ça n'a pas changé sa maman je
faire une interview benjamin
dis papa oui papa oui pour être à jamais
de premier rôle
les gens ne sont jamais marché ouais
tanaff et des navets un peu pas au
cinéma
beaucoup comme beaucoup d'autres hein
c'est comment tu fais dans un james bond
le rôle que j'ai eu c'est très frustrant
ouais surtout que lui même pas reconnu
il n'a pas vu dans le film j'ai des
moustachus lui être noir un chapeau qui
faisait pas james bond
or nous surtout près dit papa tu aurais
aimé être un héros une fois j'espère je
suis dit 'tiens ses dires des tracteurs
papa ah oui des tracteurs pas star ouais
t'as premiers rôles jusqu'au bout sinon
une enquête qui a été fait sur les dix
métiers où on gagne le moins d'argent en
france à moins de 750 euros par mois qui
a les intermittents du speed dit papa ça
jette un froid
je suis inquiet d'ambiance en l'air
voilà et c'est vrai dis papa c'est
thaïlande de faire la première compagnie
pas du tout c'est alors là encore moins
que le reste j'assume tout ce que j'ai
fait depuis 35 ans gagner du blé avec ça
pas comme tout le monde et moi tu t'es
vraiment blessé ou tu as fait ça au
moment de la pêche on m'a dit la vérité
alors j'écoute flottant de casser où il
a franchement l'a9 et l'a dit c'est ce
que tu crois que vraiment à kourou le
[ __ ] de kourou ont fait défaut ce sera
dur arrêtons la station l'a dit papa oui
tu crois que j'ai eu raison d'écrire
m'enlève l'an dernier une roue à vrai
beau temps penses quoi de ma carrière à
papa de mon fils très fier il agace
beaucoup de gens et ça me fait rire tu
es fier de moi
oui il est fier de moi c'est pas mal je
suis pas ultra la tronche de mon fils
d'adam j'aimerais bien
je suis ta merde et je pourrais dire et
c'est là qu'on n'en parle
non mais alors tu sais dans le temps
avec le temps qui passe j'ai jamais dis
papa thaïlande quand j'ai fait le loft
story ajoute ou pas surtout alors là je
dis je l'affirmé haut et fort surtout un
tu voulais que que je fasse quoi quand
j'étais petit papa je crois que le
métier d'un papa c'est de laisser faire
son fils ce qu'il a envie de faire il a
fait ce qu'il a eu envie de faire dis
papa papa oui si la trouves comment
flavie très belle ouais elle te plaît
comment mon père oui il ya des trucs que
tu m'a jamais dit papa à lui non à vous
peut-être tu m'aimes vous où lui et lui
oui il va pas tu as peur de mourir
évidemment c'est toi que deux côtes
cassées
enfin j'espère que je n'aurai pas
beaucoup on sait pas regarder ni papa
oui tu as des regrets sur ta carrière
c'est déjà énorme d'avoir de dire depuis
trente ans je vide mon métier c'est déjà
énorme
un sans être comme vous dites une star
où il veut d'être tu as pensé quoi ta
vie papa à ma vie formidable ma vie il
le sait formule était comment mamie
chiante qui veut pas savoir
pas mal comme réponse mais elle avait le
pendant de ses défauts y avait beaucoup
de qualités ouais dit papa tu aies
jamais eu envie de lui casser la gueule
à yves montand un montant non jamais non
même maintenant
[Rires]
non jamais malgré ce qu'il a fait à
maman t'as pas eu envie de lui casser la
gueule non
ce qu'il a fait à maman s'il l'a fait ça
regarde maman et mon ex-femme les bains
où il l'a fait je t'ai pas là le brave
ah oui t'as pas un peu grossi récemment
non savez le disant que je grossis
j'oublie gris selon les rôles selon
quand tu mets greek du grossiste pour
tel ou tel rôle on voit pas tellement la
différence au cedac juste pour info
c'est dans le téléfilm août étaient
maigres
et
[Musique]
jean pierre jeunet après toutes ces
questions font encore que je chéris le
pablo hasard tu vas voir
j'habite au sol
cette fois c'est juan ça vient dernière
fois c'est une jouer et jean-pierre la
dernière fois c'est hervé bourges qui à
partir des temps de chats mais je crois
qu'il a touché un ami depuis je crois
qu'il est bon ce n'est plus je serais
plus cher les leurs c'est un jeu c'est
un jeu et alors il faut que je fasse
quoi tu touches la [ __ ] d'un mec ça
devient de chat voilà mais il faut le
faire discrètement les arbitres mais tu
as une minute un sinon tu restes j'avais
toute ta vie
attention les gars y habitent
non non c'est pas valide et a pas
d'échappée vélos bixi tenter d'échapper
en touchant mais devant nous si m'aura
pas jean pierre
m
non
chaque mois
oui
[Musique]
je crois que c'est une côte en non gaap
entre un melon s'acquérir j'ai mal
[Musique]
ce shabbat shabbat shabbat ce genre ait
un seul avec maman viens d'essayer
là-bas mais la menace rôde
[Musique]
voici guillaume cochin
alors bien que charles et architectes
romancier et vous êtes le mari de perico
chat pas une mince affaire que nous
admirons tous les jours chez laurent
ruquier
comment ça se passe ça va assez plus dur
que d'être écrivain
ah oui donc oui votre deuxième roman qui
s'appelle 10 on lui connaît pas ce qu'il
a fait ouais voilà c'est vraiment
entraînant halo waypoint sepehri [ __ ]
monsieur par tous téo je viens pas
d'accord je viens si tu veux j'ai pas de
problème avait un site la femme vient
péri dommage hein ah oui
[Applaudissements]
m
payet évidemment j'allais j'allais fait
de laisser venir au casting tout seul
mais dommage que tu étais là parce qu'il
y avait un truc entre mélanie et
guillaume là je peux repartir si tu veux
c'est ce que je vais vous faire là vu
que je vous ai tous les deux une
interview à leurs torts aux séries
est-ce que tu as besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer moi je dirais les deux ça dépend
des jours à l'aller honnête tu veux dire
et toi moi ça dépend de la fille c'est
quoi ta première pensée péri quand tu te
trouve en face d'un mec séduisant je me
demande si dit la vérité la vérité c'est
est ce que je peux lui plairait ce que
ça peut aller plus loin est ce que je
sais pas non franchement je veux que tu
vois et même séduisant c'est ça chaque
fois que je te vois en tout cas c'est
quoi
tu sens pas comme des trucs qui te
pousse mais non rabarama mls c'est quoi
le lieu idéal pour une étreinte pourquoi
ce que les italiens se la machine à
laver vous saviez ça sur les orages
ouais tu resteras sauvage c'est quoi
mais pas l'intérieur un 13-4 guillaume
le lieu idéal pour une étrange juste au
pied du lit 1 avant de monter à vendôme
loir et cher à notre question c'est bon
guillaume est ce que tu préfères une
femme qui pèse bien mais qui est
infidèle ou une femme qui baisent mal
mais qui fit d'elle une femme qui laisse
bien fidèle 1 et 3 oui est ce que tu
préfères draguer de faire draguer ça
dépend qui j'ai en face de moi mais
j'aime bien me faire draguer tu devras
avec des fois oui oui je les draguer tu
préfèrerais qu'elles te quitte pour une
femme ou pour un homme pour un homme
sont simplement amis
moi aussi je peux faire et on quitte
pour un homme ouais c'est vrai est ce
que tu préfères être caressé par
quelqu'un qui très puiu battu par
quelqu'un qui t'aiment ans battu par
quelqu'un qui m'aime est ce que tu
préfères que perry couche avec un autre
en pensant à toi ou couche avec toi on
pense en un autre cas une couche avec
moi en pensant un autre moi c'est pas
mal ça qu'elle couche avec toi mais a
oui même si jamais ça continue thierry
ouais et toi tu préfères te coucher avec
toi en pensant à une autre vie couché
avec notre bonjour à toi qui couche avec
moi en pensant à moi ah c'est pas
possible c'est trop tard est ce que bon
ça fait 20 ans que cet ensemble est ce
que c'est encore un fantasmes
inavouables et non réalisés inavoués non
qu'ils ont bien fait on s'est tous dit
surtout est ce que l'amour est
compatible avec le mariage père a péri
pardon ah oui non ah si si si
complètement la preuve la preuve vivante
depuis 20 ans je les adore et j'espère
que c'est les mariés de la 2 depuis 20
ans vous êtes pas trompés jamais trompé
n'ont trompé non est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper ça dépend ce que tu sais la
réponse que tu suces perry est ce que
sucer c'est tromper si tu mens oui pour
moi tromper c'est mentir si on sent bien
c'est brest d'où son nom s'est tu ne
ment pas t'as pas trompé donc voilà
après donc sucer s'est pas trompé son
lit
donc tu vas passer jade oui j'ai cité le
poids
tu penses que quand on avoue finalement
non pas quand on avoue quand on dit oui
c'est pas à vous et à vous et ça
déflation avoué à demi nue co2 mais oui
non mais avouez c'est à dire que tu as
menti et que tu te leurs proches et
qu'ensuite tu te dis tiens je vais
l'avouer je vais le dire là c'est pas du
tout ça donc simuler s'est trompé ouais
ah oui je suis assis l'arrivée s'est
trompé on apprend des trucs corps c'est
le service public à la mairie font
l'objet d'apprendre des choses un petit
peu de gens est-ce que vous éteignez
vous allumer la lumière quand vous
baisez chez vous non franchement n'y a
pas de règle je ne suis pas t'attendrai
du toi tu non non j'ai la drague l'ibmp
82 nom n'y a pas de règle
c'est quoi la zone la plus érogène chez
toi perry bas jatte
merci il le dit pour moi
kerry avec quelles personnes ici
présentes tu aimerais avoir une aventure
soit honnête imagine conçoit dans un
monde idéal où ça pose pas de problème
on a connu ça dans les années 70 mais
bon maintenant c'est fini
un truc à plusieurs mais pas en dessous
parce qu'il fait 130 kg
alors on va aussi guillaume et honnête
avec qui tu voudrais avoir une aventure
là moi même avec ma voisine il est
génial c'est de la merde du sommet intel
allait racheter à miss france
est ce que tu préfères une femme belle
école ou une femme moche et intelligente
mal vous l'avez téléphone
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu préfères une femme
comprend sans la comprendre qu'on
comprend sans la france
on comprend sans la prendre aïe oui j'ai
pas compris des capable de ça tu vois
qu'on comprend sans la prendre je
préfère une femme qu'on comprend et
comprend pas si je pouvais posséder que
la moitié de perry tu prendrais le bas
ou le haut ou le bas le bas pourquoi là
bas parce que y'a et tu vois si vous
répondre que la moitié de guillaume tu
pourrais le bas ou le haut non moi je
prends l'eau parce que tout est dans la
tête de tous les journaux mais si
justement tout est dans la tête parce
que même si on va parler de fantasmes
sexualité et c'est assez aussi dans la
tête des gens bien d'une côte au bout du
compte ce on se rend compte par le haut
par le haut
voilà merci merci dernière question vous
baiser avant le restaurant où après le
restaurant au restaurant à l'autre ça
peut être au restaurant oui plus souvent
après paiement plus souvent après
qu'avant chaque fois que j'ai des
restaurants restant tous les soirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fais attention
rups alors qu'arte autoflagellation vous
dorer à j'adore howie vous fouetter en
nous confiant la plus grande faute de
votre carrière
est ce qu'on a le martinet méline ah oui
à le fouet à ses dépens dans la gueule
alain allez vas-y guillaume frappe mais
ça passe de quoi il parle
la terre entière
jean-pierre le fouet de guillaume
elleboudt jean pierre tu veux te voir ce
qui est dans le fruit fou du fou le
voile envoyés derrière club et l'agent
pierre insulterait en allemand vasella
[Applaudissements]
bien qu'à rester en même temps pays
envoûtant pc écoute on peut plus et là
aussi c'est un gros de ces faits dans
d'horribles tu préfères juste être
fouettée sans avouer le péché je crois
j'accueille maintenant lui simon
liberati
elle est la même chose pour moi
ouais
[Applaudissements]
ça va aller
il craint que l'état paul biya oui à
l'été
ses coups droits alors simon liberati
votre premier roman anthologie des
apparitions chez flammarion fait
beaucoup parler je dirais même que tout
le monde en parle
c'est le cas de le dire voilà alors le
pitch je vais le faire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
[Musique]
c'est fait
alors le pitch était éteinte et son
éditeur toi une telle admiration pour
simon que je louche je ne peux
m'exprimer je peux je peux pas
m'exprimer sans pleurer sur son livre je
me sers un très beau livre bien sûr je
fais le pitch d'accord alors c'est
l'histoire de claude et de sa soeur
marina durant la dolce vita des années
70 le palace le studio 54 saint tropez
ibiza voilà et aujourd'hui quand le
livre commence claude touche le rmi et
marina a disparu voilà c'est le pitch et
il passe son temps à se demander où elle
est et il passe son temps à se remémorer
la bonne époque
voilà donc c'est l'histoire de claude de
marina et puis elle est riche et puis à
la drogue
et puis à la frime et tout ça fait une
espèce de social grâce à lui sur la
grâce et sur cette gloire que certaines
personnes on a l'âge de 15-16 ans et
qu'elle ne retrouve jamais ses trousses
tiens
sauf que c'était des gens qui avaient
pas vraiment le sens des réalités dont
qu'il comprenait pas très bien comment
ça pouvait fonctionner et il y avait il
y avait des tas de gens qui tournait
autour d'eux comme des espèces de
comme les papillons autour de la lampe
finalement ils se sont fait bouffer
alors que la lampe en général elle
bouffe les papillons sont fait bouffer
par les papillons quoi voilà alors on
pense évidemment à ingrid caven de jean
jacques schuhl suite moi toi non mais si
j'en ai commencé très forte
pourquoi vous avez édité ce bouquin
frédéric dans l'argent déjà non c
éditeur c'est un métier très pénible on
lit beaucoup de choses pas terrible et
et quand j'ai lu le texte de liberati je
me suis dit ce métier est une chance ce
métier est un honneur là c'est tout ce
que j'ai à dire je sais tout ce que vous
avez à dire mais toute la critique
littéraire la saluer il ya il n'y a pas
un journaliste qui n'est pas été inspiré
sert que des types qui d'habitude
écrivent peut-être pas des articles
passionnants se met à écrire mieux en
ayant lu son livre mes talents et les
montages et en ce qui le concerne
voilà bon moi je dis je sais pas je
trouve que c'est c'est fantastique que
vous l'ayez invités il est très tard non
mais c'est important aussi parce que
c'est bon je juloux et je pense que
peut-être dans quelques décennies on
continuera de lire son livre et nous
tous on sera oublié vous avez d'autres
projets quels conseils vous lui
donneriez frédéric à simon liberati de
continuer à vivre
c'est gentil ça oui parce que c'est pas
c'est pas toujours c'est pas toujours ce
qui ressort c'est face est très charmant
j'ai eu beaucoup de textes magnifiques
etc
mais j'avais l'impression que c'était un
peu d éloge funèbre est bon c'est vrai
que c'est mon livre étant assez négatif
et donnant une image assez assez
positive de la destruction
on pouvait penser que bon voilà pourquoi
il est pourquoi il est là à essayer de
vendre ce bazar qui après tout n'est
qu'un appel à se jeter par la fenêtre
quand même malgré tout quand on le lit
et
et bon c'est sais c'est un peu là je
crois je crois que c'était là il y avait
une certaine forme de d'esprit assez à
cette époque est constitué à penser que
bon il fallait il fallait y aller à fond
et voilà quoi donc c'est le livre un peu
qui rend hommage à un certain nombre de
gens qui sont plus là forcément il ya un
certain qu'en disparu à certains qui
sont encore là mais qui sont plus
vraiment vraiment aussi jolie qu'ils
étaient à l'époque et et voilà c'est une
sorte de face et pas un hommage funèbre
mais c'est c'est c'est du sperme de
lyrisme un peu
un peu à peu nostalgique mais pas voilà
je n'ai pas plus grands machins certain
nombre de personnes qui sont plus là
quoi et maintenant on passe au musée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la limite est d'abord pour commencer le
mec qui présente son émission de
télévision pour la première fois ah bon
et bien bon soir mais aussi un musée
mais dû à pardon mesdames et messieurs
aujourd'hui c'est et si je suis très
content du temps oui la caméra fait bien
non oui alors je moi je trouve qu'il le
fait mieux que moi alors tu l'a appelée
lucien comme ton vrai prénom
oui je veux plus y aller tu l'a appelée
lucien tu veux qu'ils soient peintres ou
écrivains
j'aimerais qu'il fasse et vos seins
comme toi et je lui ai répondu tu
voudrais qu'ils paient nous qui
l'écrivons qui fasse de la musique ou
qu'il fasse les trois est archi
architecture maillée on va se marrer ce
gamin maintenant je n'aime pas ça et pas
les footeux obligera pas si vous êtes
expert comptable par exemple alors là il
aura mon coup de patin avec tout ce que
tu t'en vois tu avais pas peur qu'il
soit un peu mongolo lulu non si il
fougères
voyait pas peur et me recouvre imagina
t'as pas eu peur non mais tout ça
c'était pas tu étais pas les yeux de
porte pour oui ma bouche pipe ray de son
père ou de sa mère
c'est fini tu peux encore faire beaucoup
d'enfants comme ça c'est le dernier pas
des clones est alors imagine que tu
repars à zéro là tu remets les compteurs
à zéro tata 0 ans comme lulu et puis tu
préfères et quoi avoir le goncourt ou
être numéro 1 au top 50
ces bons coups de théâtre kodak est au
top 50 avec bien sûr c'est que tu veux
dire si tu apprenais que charlotte se
shooter un jour cette soirée quoi eh ben
je me tue tu te tue je prends une heure
12,2 de pernod alors une bonne chose
[Musique]
je suis pas très passe il admissible il
admission voilà je suis sérieux ballon
tu écoute tous sérieux une admission
je vais me tuer c'est elle qui me tue
qu'ils me tueraient père est imposée
mais charlotte ne suis je suis très
jamais serge nous tiens combien pour le
titre de vsd 5 pourquoi parce que j'aime
pas du tout le terme beurre avant oui
comme ça elle ne parle que vous
exactement comme paris je vous dis
toujours moi je suis un arabe français
mais je suis pas peur donc 5,5 et
l'hydro voix passe quand on n'aime pas
ces généreux de mettre la moyenne aux
essais sur et combien pour plusieurs
sera à 5
pourquoi parce que c'est la campagne
anti drogues
il ya un côté qui m'agace un petit peu
dans son aspect terroriste je veux dire
la drogue c'est l'alcool et tout ça
c'est aussi ce aussi du plaisir et ça on
ne le dit pas il faudrait quand même que
les gens et tous les éléments
et pour être à même de juger après alors
c'est vrai que la drogue c'est de la
merde mais c'est de la merde à longue
échéance et je trouve que c'est bien que
les gens sachent exactement donc qui
vient non pas parce que la drogue c'est
une c'est d'abord un talent c'est pas
longue échéance tabac moi je suis avec
mes chances puisque j'ai bientôt 58 ans
l'album drogue
cette mort est chiant c'est immédiat à
la tête par yahia des grandes royer qui
se portent comme des charmes enfin bon
je défends pas la drogue mais je veux
dire je j'estime que les gens doivent
avoir tous les éléments en main et 3
même de juger eux
quand vous allez les petits grains qui y
vit qui n'y connaissent rien un héros en
injectant dans le coca cola et dans
l'est dans les lycées donc ça c'est dans
la presse à sensation
non c'est la vérité hier vers moi je
veux fois jme plaques et charlotte se
saoule je ne veux pas que charlotte
shoot je dis pas que le lui ce shoot
[Applaudissements]
elle fournit on verra ça tout à l'heure
est ce que ça te laisse le temps de
s'occuper un peu des dames quand même
ben oui ça c'est un truc par contre
quand je m'occupe le plus possible le
plus possible alors j'ai lu dans une
interwiew des fois sur scène ça dure est
tellement longtemps tu étais tellement
bien que tu avais des éjaculations sur
scène c'est vrai ça ou c'est la
journaliste qui avait inventé ça on ça
m'est arrivé
ça m'est arrivé mais j'étais vraiment
bien séparées il faut croire j'espère ça
va t'arriver aujourd'hui en tous les cas
c'est bien tu réponds avec une grande
franchise
un père mastic le plus mastoc
r le plus pervers
[Musique]
c'est l'argent
en hiver
et ils vont dans l'ange loeb l'a dit à
l'adresse de la plante du ciment un
hôtel de la rive gauche
voilà ça va finir
il porte plein emploi et les [ __ ]
allons-y tendant simon simon ça vient
d'où ça ça vient de l'est de la france
et du un peu plus aussi docile
on y reprend à sa mémère et et giget mon
père était acrobates du mariage et non
en fait je parle pour lui allez ici mes
toiles mises au rebut avec excuse alors
maintenant on te demander son avis au
20e vous savez manier la ce a déjà eu
des rapports homosexuels n'ont jamais ni
avec le pen n'était pas ça découle teint
un peu hâlé convient de mettre ta bébé
avant toits des maisons des revient deux
fois dans le bayou marcherait qu'elfassi
ce match choisissent alors je ne dis
rien non je n'ai pas peur d'un contrôle
fiscal ce moment je profite ce week-end
n'a pas envie de répondre en badgeant du
cachemire indien a fait bien mieux là
hein c'est ça ben alors les politiques
tu vas voter pour qui encadraient syrien
il va voter pour qui il va voter pour
qui tout dire tout bon on verra ça plus
tard il va devenir une fois reprend la
tique est alors voitures dans des films
toute sa vie quant à simon enseignera la
favorite comme sa soixante dix ans tu
continueras à web et chacun à 70 ans à
jour récemment changé de mains pas
obligé d'être flic non
obligé pour la main sur la gueule on y
étaient beaux yeux la cdu a pas mal de
propositions de paix des non mais
arrêtez arrêtez avec vos questions
j'ai plus envie de répondre je vais te
montrer moi tu vas répondre je
reprendrai et quand tube est éteint la
lumière pas toujours pas toujours tu pas
s'ils étaient sur la table de la cuisine
ou dans la salle d'eau mais il n'y a pas
de règle là non plus il n'ya pas de
rallonger revanche ne baisse pas été
convaincu tandis que tu voudrais une
fille cassé règle voudrait vraiment
envie de cela signifie qu'à ses règles
ça va passer vraiment à la télé ça va
vraiment l'a fait ou par il leur
explique nous ce que ça fait de mettre
des capotes fait plaisir ça fait mal
voilées crise a réduit plaisir ça ait du
plaisir
sari du plaisant dupré faire attraper le
sida que m capote c'est ça non est-ce
qu'on est ce que la seule solution de
partage et le sida c'est une médaille
qu'elle en est dans la merde
quand même fait saigner je réclame un
gros plan sur le doigt elle seulement
fait saigner la série d'interviews à
totalement immonde
ça manque tellement triste de vous voir
là dedans à ça la police et au palais
gallien le biais que les bandits le cas
vous avez envie de faire quoi quand on
était petit ouais on voulait sauter
karen cheryl a maintenant qu'on la
défend la viola pure envie tu dirais si
vous tentez de les regarder en minervois
plein de boutons sous là pour moi le
maquillage son quinquennat
c'est alors c'est quoi ça à ce jour
c'est sûr c'est le foie ça c'est parce
que j'allais vous rencontrez de nicolet
ou quoi c'est possible je puis crêpes et
du a toujours ses chroniques ses boutons
du lsa toujours ça non ma main ça
m'arrive juste ont ensuite c'est un
stress sastre est cédé entre axa fait ça
peut pas le stress monte sur ta tête tu
veux toi moi ça va oui c'est quand je
vais avoir mes règle générale c'est
l'abus comment il s'appelle mario il
s'appelle comment alberto comment tu
sais maintenant allez donc comment tu ne
sais qu'ils appellent alberto s'appelle
comment il s'appelle alberto il fait
quoi
il travaille dans la mode du styliste
non non il ya des magasins les [ __ ]
leur écoute jusqu'à présent ça va il
s'en sort bien fait des deux les [ __ ]
déroule alors que moi il ne fait qu'une
seule chose il est hétéro fsif été
dépeint derrière c'est pas grave je fais
des bardages l'a dit non tu es plutôt le
sentiment d'être petits torride yens ou
vaginale comme fils je pense tout les
tous les deux tout les deux ouais ça
dépend tu pensais je dire quand tu
attrapes a d'un côté mieux vaut essayer
de tout à fait de l'autre et à mal aussi
et non on touche pas les seuls
attention didier
et au platine j'accueille l'homme qui a
fait les graph qui a fait tous les
graves qu'elles en studio à me montrer
a dit m
m
maximonstres where amazing a fait une
sélection d'enfer et là vous connaissez
le principe donc je veux l'interprète un
donc au départ il ya deux équipes il ya
l'équipe de grèce jones contre l'équipe
2 de chirel et puis après il y aura la
série des banques qu avec chacun pour sa
gueule
tout le monde connaît l'histoire tu es
prêt ramzy je suis open bar envoie le
premier morceau je veux l'interprète
attendre sur l'un des retraites
attention ramzy
qui a dit cindy lauper
[Applaudissements]
la région john l
je crois qu'on a besoin d'un petit plat
attention ramzy
c'est mort
c'est beau c'est qui exact échos
ex-aequo jean luc reichmann jean louis
vachon un peu le goût de la vie en même
temps
[Applaudissements]
sabeg levin ça fait un point partout
voilà on commencerait proprement avec un
point partout c'est quoi la et
maintenant je dis ramzy deuxième morceau
natation s'est jamais
[Musique]
et
je nie
m
elle
et
[Musique]
tenez bon on a bien regardé ici même si
je crois que c'est le point et 8° john
allez
c'est tout est là ce clash plus qu'à spa
rôle à meaux
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est un poids pour l'équipe de
graisse jaune puisque c'est quelqu'un de
ce côté là qui répondu j'aimerais
simplement public
ja je veux signaler bayal public qui
jonathan non je veux signaler au public
dans mon âme se signaler au public loire
on a vu cette année que si vous répondez
avant les invités le point va à l'autre
équipe qui si les invités ne trouve pas
et vous répondez le point bas à cette
équipe d'accord ok c'est bien là le
public a répondu ce côté là c'est donc
graisse jaune ce qui marque un point
l'équipe du bassin
djamel concentre toi là comme dit sa
robe bleue en même temps j'avais jamais
entendu cette chanson c'est par boys et
un remix
attention donc maintenant maintenant je
lui dis que c'est un robot c'est
mustapha dance way qui a remixé les
clashs mois voilà les cinq ans car au
musée bon même si là aussi attention
faisait près elle a bombardé un jeune
jamais
on est un peu partout attention c'est
très bagarrer comme comme conteste ce
soir on passe au numéro quatre amis s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
c'est une erreur grave alors il a dit il
a dit le nom du titre et quel est le
groupe qui interprète son mensonge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me rends du groupe la vie
taisez vous oui personne ici personne le
public
bonjour à vos marques
[Applaudissements]
ouais
une
[Applaudissements]
ça fait deux points pour l'équipe de
chirel trois points pour l'équipe de
glen johnson
c'est ça me voulait faire au début je
voulais pas faire le malin ok on l'a dit
et redit renzi il ya un truc que je te
propose là ouais parce que là je vois
que l'ambiance commence à chauffer mais
moi j'ai mes potes qui sont l'avant
j'aimerais bien qu'il vienne bas qui
viennent
hé les gars bien tu de la cité qui va
arriver dans tous les artistes art et
musique
donc voilà
m
alors s'il vous plaît les amis vous vous
répartissez voilà quoi vous jouez jouez
y joue pas tes potes mais non elle joue
pas assez sur alain ils connaissent tous
isabelle ça te rappelle le pays droit
qui fait ça va dans le sine qua non
examinons comment alors ramzy maintenant
on passe au numéro 5
attention on souffle pas les mecs
intentions samedi comme julie et la
platine ne marche pas avec tes conneries
je te jure je sais de qui la plaque qui
ne marche pas c'est qu'elle gonfle je
sais pas qui était normal que ça va j'ai
tendu maigrir ça ne marche pas
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ma musique
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ils sont bien ses potes ramzy ils sont
très bien battus musique c'est les plus
forts
ouais faut pas chercher ses glorieux et
stéphane et miami 100 machines
attention pas ce numéro 7 6 n'empêche
que les très riches et ouais
[Applaudissements]
chanel djamel menad djamel tu peux les
réponses du bois mais aurait été marvin
gaye sa barre c'est toute mon enfance
dit tout ça c'était banking systems are
being et non à noter quoi colette renard
c'est quoi ça
miami sont deux machines mort il ya une
heure acheter j'ai fait la réclamation
thierry giami sa machine est évident
mais ça c'est parce que tu as triché je
le savais avant un temps en temps
arrêtez tout de suite samedi
l'embrouillé laval nous fait une
embrouille face on note la belle chante
jamais c'est leur mobile
la boulaye jamais sur les bords des bacs
à passer comme ma vie je veux dire ninh
binh thuan trois points pour l'équipe de
continuer j'ai triché ce saint homme un
moment
[Applaudissements]
il continue continue
il fallait refaire sur sa non j'aurais
jamais dû faire un blind test s'est
dérobée je suis perdu je suis perdu bon
c'est pas toujours cérisola n'ont jamais
vu dans ma vie dit bon ménage
alors ça va mais vie mais quatre partout
laisse tomber
mais ce cas partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
google
jojo 16 heures bon vous êtes antisémites
antisémites et perde son sang-froid
trust bien attention à ce que je crois
que le parti m'attendais d'un stop ça ce
que je propose c'est que là maintenant à
4 4 et où tu mets tu mets la chanson
numéro 7 et tout le monde je normalement
s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce qui sont ici
un lidar idéal c'est toute une horde
vocale aussi normalement
vas-y tire à la chanson numéro cette
chanson numéro 9 très bien bien vu
etienne j'ai une bonne recrue
vas-y g 10 jean
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
dambach
bon tout les cas je sais pas qui gagne
mais moi je me régale un bonheur on
continue en 10 continue
[Musique]
yahoo
[Applaudissements]
sur quoi comme a grandi à mesure
à
[Musique]
oui
jeudi
je pense pas non comment tu t'appelles
commence à souffler comment tu
t'appelles avait comme le futur mari de
chirel il s'appelle david alors mazel
tov
bon moi je la vis de magna je vais pas
les mêmes chantiers mais peu importe en
même temps c'est cesser de la musique
c'est de la bonne musique
ça commençait pas comme com com com non
non non ils échangent les finales bon
alors ouais l'original d'accord au fait
désolé n'en obtenir que rami g dinars
anzhi dis moi ce que tu veux qu'on fasse
parce que c'est pas les mêmes types
chien c'est la suite ah ouais je
continue la suite ok bon basique journée
tranquille pépère mais ce soir c'est pas
devenus ces 10 acteurs choisis
chichi
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
m
alors les conversions de cette chanson
je voudrais que tu fasses quelques pas
de danse sur scène sur cette musique
parce que je t'ai vue d'un événement
spécial à partir des gens n'ont-ils
énorme quand il danse là dessus
attention jose comme les cocos un petit
robot pacifique en voilà on s'en fout du
blind test en branle du blind test loge
attention gardez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamel debbouze montant rôdera xiwanzi
nom alors je vais te dire alors à passer
directement aux banques aux bonbons qu
on passera encore à basseau beaucoup
dans ce cas on va pas y arriver donc
mais vis tu effaces son ardoise ne donne
qu'un avis c'est bien à cela c'est bien
fait mais reconnaît le plein on fait un
saut bongo on passe au mans 18ème
l'andorre la fumée qui perd beaucoup
c'est chacun pour sa gueule branco tu
prennes on n'a pas voulu faire un plat
ne reste pas beaucoup ça rien n'arrête
jamais
jamais mais c'est manqué mais enfin qui
en veut à la le mans corps aux mots je
connais car sinon vous aurez nikhil
blonde qu'elle alors le banco bon connu
si on me dit qu'il faut refaire l'amiral
de gaulle
au caire ils ont moins la 12 nous
restons baissiers mois les banques au
nom je te jure je n'en laisse tomber
témoin les bons coups là vous avez
unique et déteste c'est pas moi c'est
bien là mais je sais mais bon quitte le
quai ouest et bars alors le replay du
dernier d'avoir fait mal et banco et et
les banques où vous connaissez le
principe c'est chacun pour sa gueule
donc là il ya pas la solution il n'y a
pas de discussion possible
donc pour toi c'est la 14e attention je
veux la [ __ ] ya plus d'équipés ya
plus d qui place et chacun bonsoir
salazie ramzy bazire ami wayne sur way
certains ouais on est parti ouais djamel
tu triches bah ouais ouais
ouais
la vie ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
à
ban qui a marqué bien marqué l'an ma
fille ok on continue avec moi ah bon ex
aequo des séries de l'année dernière la
première sera de lille avec attention
super banco c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile de faire laisse tomber on a les
galères au delà
[Musique]
oui
ma question ça c'est pop up the volume
qui chante i iia faut un nom bref on
remballe là non las des scandales un nom
mars
ouais j'ai gagné le super boulot
commandé par m
et là moi je suis venu j'ai gagné super
beaucoup je reviens une deuxième fois je
le gagne trop fort c'est l'unité bon
maintenant le méga bon compte fumée
tristan mergault le méga banco
[Musique]
moi j
quoi non non non non qui chante ça
j'suis galles dont amer je vous ai donné
la sortie voilà tu me regardes dit qui
chante attendait maintenant bien plus
grave que tu le dis pas et il ya plus
qu'un truc c'est voudra l'ultrabook
autre est bienvenu avant qu un message
de l'huissier du jeu qui vient de
démissionner john lettre au journal m
landon a démissionné
attention est celui qui trouve
j'ai fait une visite guidée des jeunes
tu connais que celui envisagé le départ
18h
[Musique]
bouton à puteaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo quoi quoi
yen trop fort trop fort il fallait le
trouver
c'est vraiment très fort qu'il chantait
cgd françois fillon comment je peux
connaître sa part françois fellmann
l'encyclopédie de la fin que c'est moi
je crois que tout le monde aura compris
que tu manques à gagner tu m'en a perdu
c'est un peu comme l'école des fans de
jacques martin voilà merci ramzy tu as
bien [ __ ] taviani qui grâce à genevois
de toute l'histoire de tous les plans tu
avais tu as raison c'est le plus grand
mal à l'aise qu'on ait jamais vu
complètement 10,3 y est mais très sympa
et assez plat radicale malgré tout le
quartier delseny flash rien 18 mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir donner le meilleur
[Musique]
les marques
barcamp
ma part
[Musique]
bayonne
pas
[Musique]
oh
bah
[Musique]
ce match